[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver pour le temps fort de la
semaine au sénat la question d'actualité
au gouvernement
ça commence à 15h précisément une heure
et une quinzaine de questions pour
interpeller le gouvernement mais avant
cela
pas de changement de cap sociale à
l'horizon les réformes retraite
assurance chômage sont maintenus
emmanuel macron l'a confirmé hier aux
présidents de groupes parlementaires
reçus à l'elysée dans le cadre de ses
consultations
la préco vite va-t-il ressembler à
l'avant pandémie notre face à face à
14h30
dans un instant notre grand débat
s'intéresse aux propositions de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
révolution participative pour les uns à
posture démocratique pour les autres
cette convention état légitime
on se pose la question dans un instant
et puis le rendez vous à ne pas manquer
c'est bien sûr les questions d'actu à 15
heures on me nuit bien des questions
notamment sur cette convention citoyenne
on vous fait vivre tout ça cette semaine
avec style jourdain salle des
conférences
et surtout n'hésitez pas à commentaires
agira cette émission avec le hashtag qu
âgées
[Musique]
et pour l'instant on va tout de suite
rejoindre steve jourdain salle des
conférences je le disais steve dans une
heure vont commencer les questions
d'actu alors quels thèmes se détache
steve bonjour tam actualité chargée
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle vous
l'évoquez il sera question de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat lors
on le sait la convention a rendu ses
conclusions dimanche dernier à l'as
remis un rapport de 600 pages à la
ministre de la transition écologique
elisabeth bande parmi les propositions
évoquées et qui font débat la création
d'un crime d' écocide afin de
sanctionner les atteintes à
l'environnement
une question sera posée au gouvernement
sur ce thème du côté des socialistes
autre thème discuté dans l'hémicycle
l'urgence économique et sociale on sait
que les prévisions de croissance de la
france ont été revues à la baisse on
attend désormais un repli de 11% 11 %
pour l'année 2020
comment éviter une débâcle sociale et
économique à la rentrée puis en
définitive comment préserver bien les
emploient plusieurs questions seront
posées sur ce thème au gouvernement
notamment dans les rondes dans les rangs
de l'union centriste il sera aussi
question aujourd'hui du projet de loi de
finances rectificatif troisième texte
ans déjà visant à ajuster les comptes
publics pour l'année 2020 ses comptes
publics on sait sont très touchés par la
crise sanitaire et économique dans ce
texte qui est actuellement sur le bureau
de l'assemblée nationale le gouvernement
prévoit est bien de venir en aide à
certains secteurs particulièrement
touchés par la crise on pense notamment
aux secteurs du tourisme ou encore au
secteur culturel
le gouvernement sera interpellé à ce
sujet par les républicains et puis on
est un peu étonné il n'y aura pas de
questions tam au programme sur les
dernières révélations de mediapart sur
la sphère alexis kohler pas de question
non plus sur la série fillon qui sera
vous le savez jugé lundi prochain mais
on reste bien sûr attentif damas qui se
passe dans l'hémicycle les choses
peuvent encore changer en tout cas on
reste dans celle des conférences et
dessinateur viendront bien sûr répondre
à nos questions à ce micro les questions
au gouvernement c'est vous l'avais dit
dans une heure merci beaucoup et steve
pour toutes ces explications et pour ce
menu alléchant
on vous retrouve bien sûr tout au long
de cette émission avec de nombreux
invités à votre micro
mais pour l'heure on passe au premier
débat de cette émission
que faire des propositions de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat 149
mesures parmi lesquels l'inscription de
l'ecosite dans la loi ou l'abaissement
de la vitesse sur les autoroutes à 110
km heure faut-il organiser un référendum
opportunité ou piège pour emmanuel
macron on va se poser toutes ces
questions sur ce plateau avec nos
invités mais d'abord retour sur les
propositions de cette convention et le
débat qui s'ouvre sur la légitimité de
la convention climat sagna des chiens
149 propositions pour réduire nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de 40%
d'ici 2030 les 150 citoyens tirés au
sort l'été dernier pour plancher sur le
sujet ont rendu leur copie au
gouvernement
il propose par exemple une rénovation
énergétique obligatoire pour tous les
bâtiments d'ici 2040 une taxe sur les
dividendes ou encore la limitation de la
vitesse autorisée à 110 km/heure sur
autoroute des mesures issues de neuf
mois de réunions de débats et finalement
d'un vote de cet échantillon de français
tirés au sort pour proposer des
solutions au changement climatique
une démarche voulue par emmanuel macron
après l'échec de la taxe carbone qui
avait provoqué la crise des gilet jaune
vous avez réussi une première dans un
système politique qui est construit à l'
inverse de ce que vous avez fait la
démocratie délibérative en france c'est
pas la tradition politique et donc c'est
énorme
l'innovation démocratique qui s'est
déroulée aujourd'hui le 29 juin les 150
citoyens sont invités à rencontrer
emmanuel macron c'est lui qui décidera
du sort de leurs propositions
le président de la république peut
choisir de les soumettre à un référendum
ou au vote du parlement
mais au sénat la droite se montre
critique sur cette méthode du tirage au
sort
ces gens là je vais remet absolument pas
en cause leurs convictions personnelles
et leur sens de l'engagement sur des
sujets comme le climat maintenant la
stabilité c'est aux élus de la voir il y
as on est dans une république
démocratique tout ce qui est le plus
démocratique et donc je trouve préféré
que ça se fasse dans ce cadre là et que
si les gens veulent changer
d'orientation politique ça se fasse dans
les urnes les urnes c'est justement
l'une des options proposées par les
citoyen pour légitimer leurs
propositions ils veulent tant sous m 2
un référendum inscrire la lutte contre
le changement climatique dans le premier
article de la constitution et créer un
crime déco site dans le droit pénal et
pour débattre sur ce plateau j'ai eu le
plaisir d'accueillir mathilde himer
bonjour vous êtes membre du comité de
gouvernance de la convention citoyenne
cofondatrice de démocratie ouverte
également sur ce plateau clients gontard
sénateur écologiste de l'isère vous êtes
rattaché au groupe communiste et je
précise que vous êtes vice présidente de
la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
également avec nous jérôme bignon
bonjour aux sénateurs les indépendants
de la somme vous est également membre de
cette même commission de l'aménagement
du territoire et du développement
durable et enfin j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir à distance en
visioconférence jean-philippe delsol
bonjour vous êtes avocat fiscaliste
président de l'iref l'institut de
recherches économiques et fiscales à
leur première question pour vous ma team
air est ce que vous comprenez ce débat
qui monte sur la légitimité et la
représentativité de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat on entend
notamment et bien à droite des voix qui
s'élèvent sur l aire vos propositions
je pense que le débat il est assez
naturel ce quelque chose de nouveau en
france on a l'habitude d'avoir un
système politique jacobins à séoul les
experts ont une large place donc c'est
normal que le débat ait lieu c'est
normal que le tirage au sort pose
question aujourd'hui en france ce qui
est rassurant c'est quand on regarde les
exemples dont on s'est inspiré pour
monter cette convention citoyenne pour
le climat notamment en irlande qui a
permis la légalisation de l'avortement
bien une assemblée citoyenne tirés au
sort puis un référendum est ce qu'on
voit c'est que il est même question de
légitimité sur le processus en irlande
puis finalement la légation d'avortement
a balayé la question de la légitimité
qui a prouvé que finalement ça
représentait les irlandais pour une
raison simple c'est que les votes au
sein de l'assemblée citoyenne sur la
légalisation de l'avortement ont été les
mêmes au référendum des français
derrière les irlandais guillaume gontard
votre réaction vous comment est ce que
vous considérez les résultats des
travaux de la convention citoyenne sur
le climat ce que c'est une vraie parole
citoyenne qui est libéré est ce que
c'est une une expérimentation démocratie
participative parce que c'est une
fumisterie comme on l'entend dire à à
droite
d'abord et c'est une expérience
démocratique inédite
inédite en france donc moi je salue déjà
rien que l'expérience
et puis le fait de se dire que quand on
tire 150 personnes au sort qu'on prend
du temps puisque c'était sur huit neuf
mois qui a du travail qui a des experts
et bien que en fait voilà on fait
confiance à ses citoyens que
l'intelligence collective en fait ma
porte ses fruits et avec ses 150
propositions fin 149 qui ont été quant à
eux été retenue on voit que je dirais
que les citoyens ont fait leur travail
et moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est que
maintenant on passe là on passe la main
vers les verts les parlementaires et que
d'une certaine manière on renforce les
parlementaires jérôme bignon vous
d'abord sur et bien la légitimité de
cette convention citoyenne est elle
légitime la question du tirage au sort
pose question pour certains ils tirage
au sort c'est vieux comme l'humanité
les grecs tiré au sort les citoyens qui
était appelé à diriger la la
collectivité de la vie de la cité
j'ai relu sécuroute chaud alors on
pourrait considérer que nous rousseau
est un dangereux révolutionnaire et on
sait ce que ne l'était pas ils étaient
tous les deux d'accord pour dire que le
tirage au sort et est pas inintéressant
parce que c'était une contribution assez
pertinente on peut pas faire de la
démocratie directe quand on est soixante
cinq millions ont fait de la démocratie
représentative c'est la base
mais qu'on est une respiration citoyenne
surtout que les citoyens lui disent pas
je veux me substituer ils disent je veux
apporter une contribution qu'on les aide
à apporter cette contribution qu'on
construise petit à petit une réflexion
mature sur la façon d'apporter cette
réflexion etc
moi je trouve ça plutôt intelligent je
suis allé à iéna quand le président de
la république est venu au mois de
janvier pour dire la vérité j'y suis
allé à céret 2,6 en juillet en bois mais
enfin j'y suis quand même allé passé ma
soirée palais d'iéna la wii à ses yeux
et je suis sorti on me disait j'ai
changé d'avis en y étant parce que je me
suis dit c'est vraiment une opportunité
il y avait que des braves gens ce qu'on
voit dans nos circonscriptions dans nos
départements qu'on a l'habitude de
croiser qui nous parlent plus d'habitude
deux des sujets qui ont été évoqués la
au café là ils avaient été regroupés il
y travaillait plutôt intelligemment et
de bonne humeur
donc je me dis c'est un vrai atout ça ne
se substitue pas sa complète
à droite certains sont beaucoup plus
sévères que vous regardez par exemple
bien la réaction de philippe bas le
président l ère de la commission des
lois dans un tweet
il parle de sa déception face aux
résultats de la prétendue convention
citoyenne reprise de la vulgate du lobby
écologiste et regardez ce qu'il écrit
pour le coup lui à la fin le tirage au
sort a confirmé comme imposture
démocratique
votre réaction jean-philippe delsol en
tout d'accord yport en réalité s'agit-il
vraiment d'un tirage au sort il y a deux
cent cinquante mille personnes ont été
contactées et puis il ya un filtre et
finalement ce sont ceux qui étaient les
plus motivés les plus militants qui se
sont déclarés et parmi lesquels ont été
choisis un certain nombre de gens et
finalement on aboutit un processus qui
est le processus de manipulation
c'est une tyrannie des manipulateurs à
laquelle on arrive c'est à dire en
réalité on a mis 150 personnes ensemble
avec des pertes des lobbyistes qui sont
insérés au coeur de cette assemblée et
qui ont fait monter la mayonnaise
c'est à dire qu'ils ont fait en sorte
que petit à petit il est une sorte de
surenchère permanente
quel qu'en soit le coût et on arrive
finalement à un processus qui est
totalement populiste est totalement
dangereux comme rousseau finalement qui
effectivement favoriser une certaine
manière le tirage au sort mais avec ce
risque qu'il évoquait dans le contrat
social de dire oui c'est la volonté
générale qui s'expriment et qui
contraint tous ceux qui s'y refusent par
tout leur corps ce qu'ils disent est il
expliqué t-il
veut dire qu'on renforcera les gens être
libre et là on veut nous forcer en fait
un écologisme malgré nous
malgré le débat démocratique qui ne
s'est pas instaurer qui n'a été qu'une
sorte de global manipulation philippe
delsol ça fait beaucoup réagir en
plateau jérôme bignon s'entendait bien
désolé cher confrère d'être en désaccord
profond
oui la manipulation oui la manipulation
quand un groupe s'exprime conte qui
s'expriment librement en france en dix
ans sous la forme associative
là c'est vrai que c'est organisé mais il
y en a il ya d'autres associations qui
sont organisés et qui moi j'aime mieux
l'association qui est organisé par
l'état sous couvert de spécialistes qui
les encadrent qu'ils aident à réfléchir
et c'est que des manipulations qui sont
eux organisé par des groupes inféodés à
des puissances étrangères ou un thé ou
inféodés à des à des idéologies que je
ne partage absolument pas il ya moins de
danger de le faire avec la la convention
citoyenne qu'avec certains groupuscules
qui manipulent les idées à travers
internet me semble-t-il
mathilde et mr votre réaction mais juste
peut-être pourrait expliquer comment
s'est fait le tirage au sort est de
montrer que ce qui vient des dix est
factuellement faux ce que monsieur del
sol dit il y avait 250 mille personnes
tirées au sort et puis finalement on a
choisi et ce choix il est il est biaisé
alors on veut être qu'est ce qui s'est
passé il ya en effet deux cent cinquante
mille numéros de téléphone qui ont été
générés aléatoirement par l'institut de
sondage harris est évidemment sous le
contrôle la nuit c'est qu'on était
appelée et pour qu'ils par une assemblée
de 150 hommes cadres supérieurs qui sont
ceux qui peuvent se permettre tout de
suite de dire oui on a mis six critères
pour être représentatif de la population
ces critères qui sont lesquels d'abord
un critère de sexe il ya autant de
femmes et d'hommes dans cette population
que dans la proportion française un
critère d'âge un critère de csp un
critère de niveau de diplôme un critère
de zones géographiques
un critère de typologie de zones
géographiques qui permet dans cette
assemblée d'avoir sur ces tous ces
critères là la même proportion que dans
la société française je prends un
exemple sans opposer à l'assemblée
nationale et à l'assemblée nationale on
a un ouvrier
c'est 20 % de la population française
dans cette assemblée
je crois à 18 % d'ouvriers assez proche
de la réalité
ce qui veut dire je suis pas en train de
dire qu'il faut remplacer l'assemblée
nationale par le tirage au sort par
contre que ça vient compléter un
dysfonctionnement des rampes de la
représentation qu'on voit élection après
élection abstentions après abstention
populisme et la montée du populisme
après la montée du populisme à chaque et
pendant ce temps en tout cas la droite
qui s'oppose un plus tôt à toutes les
propositions de la convention citoyenne
et de fait il est vrai que les
propositions place plutôt aux
écologistes ou à la gauche écouté par
exemple olivier faur le patron du ps il
était hier l'invité de notre matinale
écoutez il ya dans cette dans ce
collectif qui s'est rassemblée pendant
neuf mois des travaux extrêmement
intéressant et qui mérite débat est
reprise et donc j'espère ce sera un
moment historique de basculement on
parle de mesures bascule derrière des
mots mesures qui permettent de changer
complètement le modèle mais là il ya des
mesures qui peuvent pas mettre de façade
basculante oui votre réaction
jean-philippe delsol
est ce que vous estimez que du coup et
bien ses propositions elle émane plutôt
de la gauche que de la droite quelle
conclusion vous tirer et bien du fait
que de fait les propositions puissent
plus aux écologistes quel à droite pour
l'instant mais en réalité d'abord on n'a
même pas posé la question prioritaire et
préalable est-ce qu'il faut lutter
contre le climat
on est parti du principe qu'il fallait
lutter contre une hausse de température
que certains contestent ou du moins
certains contestent qu'elle souhaite lui
alors c'est certain qu'on teste qu'on
puisse la combattre par des moyens
humains
alors là on n'a pas du tout ce débat là
et on est parti sur le fait qu' il
fallait combattre qu'il fallait prendre
des mesures qu'il fallait avoir toujours
plus toujours plus contre quel qu'en
soit le coût contre la température qui
augmente et à partir de là s'est
enclenché une sorte de processus
purement révolutionnaire très habituel
de foule qui fait qu' on s'entraîne les
uns les autres à dire toujours plus
celui qui gagne c'est celui qui va plus
loin encore qu'ils essayent d'obtenir
toujours plus et on en arriver à une
sorte de consensus qu'il est quasi
révolutionnaire parce qu'en fait ces
mesures sont effectivement très viola
trice des libertés
et qui sont dangereuses consensus
révolutionnaire mesure viola trice des
libertés et guillaume gontard votre
réaction
mais moi je pense en fait ce qui s'est
passé c'est exactement c'est exactement
l'inversé puisque je viens d'entendre
c'est pas très sympathique et
respectueux pour les citoyennes et les
citoyens au sens large parce que je
pense qu'on peut leur faire confiance et
que bien sûr qu'il ya des lobbys bien
sûr qu'il ya des pressions mais comme
nous on peut en avoir et il me semble
que moi je fais confiance à
l'intelligence de citoyennes et de
citoyens donc ça c'est c'est une
première chose après il me semble qu'on
est quand même on a eu les gilet jaune
on a eu on sait qu'on doit retravailler
on doit réfléchir aînés cratie à une
manière de fonctionner jaune pression
que ça a déjà et moi je suis intéressé
par ces réactions parce qu'en fait c'est
que ça bouscule ça dérange et ça c'est
ce qui est intéressant c'est que il faut
qu'on il faut qu'on réfléchisse à une
autre manière et on est plutôt dans une
période il va falloir concret moi je
pense que rêve de réchauffement
climatique c'est pas juste une lobby de
certains dons c'est quelque chose qui
est qui et qui existe qui une lubie qui
est réel on avait 45 degrés au paul donc
je pense que c'est plus voilà enfin je
pense que les discours que je viens
d'entendre je pense qu'on peut ça y est
maintenant sa salle devant devrait plus
les on devrait plus les entendre par
contre c'est maintenant comment
collectivement on avance et on passe à
l'acte et moi je pense que maintenant
c'est là où on en est avec ce que
viennent de sortir ses 150 c 50 citoyens
c'est comment on utilise ce qui a été
fait et ce pour terminer ce qu'est ce
qui est intéressant c'est ce qui a été
dit c'est que effectivement on prend
soin 50 citoyens tirés au sort et pas de
manière assez pragmatique à ces
pratiques assez réaliste bah c'est vrai
que ça regroupe beaucoup de propositions
faites par les écologistes
alors je pense que c'est pas totalement
un hasard il ya un autre argument c'est
que eh bien certains craignent aussi et
bien que cela empiète sur le pouvoir du
parlement prenez bien ces demandes du
conseil constitutionnel très sévère dans
une tribune qui a été publiée par le
figaro
ces deux membres du conseil
constitutionnel qui juge que cette
expérience fut me fais du parlement et
du gouvernement de simple courroie de
transmission d'une volonté populaire
supérieure et qu'ils sont sommés de
transformer cette volonté en loi ayant
un règlement est ce que c'est le cas
jérôme dijoux lui qui sont ces bons deux
anciens membres du
du conseil constitutionnel dont la
banque était un ancien collaborateur de
jean pierre raffarin est ce que vous
vous sentez en tant qu'élu de la nation
tout de même court circuité par cette
initiative assez curieux puisque ça fait
quand même vingt ans que je suis
parlementaire
donc j'ai une j'ai une vue unique à
aucun moment je me sens court circuiter
jusqu'au bout du compte c'est moi qui
votent alors un référendum c'est le
peuple ça on peut pas enlever ce pouvoir
au peuple
si c'est un sujet d'importance
constitutionnelle que le président de la
république le décide ça fait partie de
la constitution donc rien de choquant à
ça ici c'est une loi belle et voté avec
la majorité de l'époque c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale il ya une
opposition plutôt à la majorité de
l'assemblée nationale au sénat
bon et puis on trouve 80 % des cas on
trouve des accords entre nous avec des
culs des conclut des commissions des
commissions mixtes paritaires qui
aboutissent donc on n'est pas dans une
et pas dans la guerre on est on est
plutôt dans une espèce de con
construction qui valent que cahin caha
mais qui marche pas si mal et qui est
des gens que qu'on interdise aux gens de
faire des propositions je veux dire
toute la journée il ya des gens qui font
des provisions
moi je reçois 50 l'aide par semaine de
gens qu'il irait si vous changez ça si
vous faisiez ça et pourquoi vous faites
pas ça tout le temps
pourquoi d'organiser cette participation
citoyenne constitue une une photo
originale et suggère que c'est plutôt à
mon avis un enrichissement de la
démocratie alors maintenant la question
qui se pose c'est effectivement que
faire je suis l'amour en position vous
êtes de droite je veux dire parce que
modélisation que faire des propositions
de la convention citoyenne vous l'avez
dit guillon de montard c'est maintenant
la question qui se pose il ya un
engagement présidentiel et les membres
de la convention climat bien veulent le
rappelait emmanuel macron regardez bien
ce clip qui est sorti juste après ces
propositions ce qui sortira de cette
convention
je m'y engage sera soumis sans filtre
soit au vote du parlement soit
référendum soit application
réglementaire direct
pendant neuf mois on a bossé comme des
fous les soirs les week ends on a
auditionné des scientifiques des
économistes des banquiers des
agriculteurs des juristes des
syndicalistes des urbanistes des chefs
d'entreprise des ministres on a
construit un plan pour éviter la
catastrophe climatique et sociale mais
aussi pour que notre futur à tous soit
plus beau on a cherché des solutions qui
respecterait tout le monde
le froid plus tard les citoyens ont fait
le job et maintenant c'est au président
de tenir sa parole ça étonne peut-être
sa rencontre harry d'autres se faisaient
peut-être en tant que ce n'était pas
arrivé mais je fais ce que je dis
alors pour eux pour nous pour les
français ont commencé à votre tour
monsieur le président de tenir votre
engagement comme nous à compter de
maintenant c'est à votre tour monsieur
le président mathilde himer vous
l'attendait au tournant le président de
la république il reçoit la semaine
prochaine la convention citoyenne que
doit-il faire pour vous la tente des 150
citoyens c'est qui tienne son engagement
avec le même sérieux que le sérieux
qu'ils ont mis pendant ces noces mon
travail je voulais dire que le prix très
saturé tenir son engagement
ça veut dire de passer son filtre les
propositions à l'avoir alimentaire à la
voie référendaire ou la voie
parlementaire
le choix qu'ont fait les 150 il est
important je compte des avis du
parlement c'est sur les 149 mesure
d'envoyer 3 au référendum
le préambule de la constitution
l'article 1 de la constitution et
l'écocide qui passe par la loi tout le
reste
la balle est remise au parlement et le
sans fil ce qui s'applique au président
de la république
les citoyens ont bien compris ils se
sentent pas en opposition en conflit en
en concurrence avec les parlementaires
mais en plus envie de travailler avec
eelv ont d'ailleurs entamé une démarche
où ils ont déclenché des rendez vous
avec l'ensemble des groupes
parlementaires pour travailler ensemble
ça je pense que c'est un signe de
confiance vers les français sur la
question du référendum mais aussi vers
les parlementaires représentant du club
par une autre manière
à travers ce choix qui a été fait le
week-end dernier
jean-philippe delsol votre votre
réaction est bien à cette proposition de
sans filtre dans cette promesse en fait
d'emmanuel macron de sans fil de
traduire et bien ces propositions de la
convention citoyenne
je crois que ça prouve essentiellement
l'inquiétude dans laquelle elle monsieur
macron qui a cherché à se sortir d'une
situation
de fines finalement ne baisse dans les
sondages pour lui et dommageable et il
s'est mis dans un piège
il sévit dans le piège du sans filtre
c'est à dire qu'il s'est mis dans le
piège
j'ai eu une petite réunion de 150
personnes qui je les dis déjà tout à
l'heure mais manipuler ont fait des
propositions qui sont toutes ou presque
excessive et à partir de là en réalité
bien sûr jérôme bignon a raison ce sont
les parlementaires qui décideront in
fine et ne faut pas dire ce sont ses 105
ans qui ont décidé mais les
parlementaires sont mis sous pression
on leur fait croire que c'est l'opinion
qui veut ça et ça n'est pas vrai alors
jean philippe delsol on va regarder un
petit peu d'un les 149 proposition
sortie de la convention citoyenne calyon
à 149 on va regarder juste quelques unes
ya parmi les plus médiatiques la
limitation à 110 km h sur les autoroutes
l'écocide inscrit dans la loi qui doit
donner lieu à un référendum il ya aussi
l'interdiction des terrasses chauffées
ou encore l'interdiction des vols
intérieurs lorsque le trajet peut être
fait en train en moins de 4 heures - ya
cent quarante neuf propositions cet
énorme
qu'est ce que vous pensez eh bien vous
de ces propositions jérôme bignon et de
cet engagement du président de la
république allait traduire sans filtre y
en a car une partie ça va être par
référendum
normalement il faut pas tout mélanger il
ya des propositions qui vont donner lieu
à des lois il ya des divisions qui vont
donner lieu à des décrets la partie du
gouvernement il choisira ce qui
l'intéresse le parlement un pouvoir de
contestation mais n'a pas de pouvoir
d'opposition pouvoir réglementaire du
parlement donc du lit du gouvernement je
veux dire que si c'est la loi c'est la
majorité qui décide c'est c'est le
système démocratique alors 110 km heure
sur l'autoroute c'est comme les 80
stades est un décret oui c'est pas c'est
pas donc si le gouvernement désire ce
qui demande la modification de la
constitution et qui pourrait donc
constituer ce mercredi un référendum le
cds français qui décide qui décideront
si le le crime ne les lui
les définir un crime déco site c'est pas
nécessairement c'est pas nécessairement
à passer à jeu par la constitution sauf
si on veut l'inscrire dans la
constitution c'est dans le code pénal
le par contre la modification de
l'article du principe que la conscience
ion ça c'est évidemment un ou un
référendum ou une démarche
constitutionnelle avec un aller retour
devant le parlement et versailles tout
ça et est envisageable et il n'est pas
du tout dit que le parlement ne serait
pas d'accord pour le l'article 1 sur le
sur le sur l'article la durée ferrol du
de la constitution mais je pense qu'il
serait même assez d'accord le parlement
l'a tué les grecs aussi pourrait
vraiment faire débat parce qu'il ya
quand même eu déjà deux propositions de
loi qui ont été déposées et bien dans
les deux chambres les deux fois elles
ont été refusées par la majorité
guillaume montage qui a besoin d'y
revenir je voudrais juste mentionné ce
qu'on peut lire dans le canard enchaîné
aujourd'hui avec et bien et d'or
philippe billy qui dit que non il est en
complet désaccord avec les côtiers des
le canard enchaîné qui au titre c'est
cuit pour le référendum
c'est peut-être la difficulté parce
qu'effectivement dans les mesures que
vous avez vous avez montré que ce soit
que ce soit l'écocide que ce soit le
chauffage des terrasses etc
c'est des choses qu'on a déjà débattu
qui sont passés soit sous forme
d'amendement soit sous forme de
deux textes puisqu'il y avait un texte
du parti socialiste sur l'ecosite dont
on a discuté il ya pa très il ya pas
très longtemps
moi je pense que le danger justement
c'est de prendre mesures comme ça
séparément des autres et que le travail
de la convention justement femmes en
tout cas c'est comme ça que l'analyse
c'est vraiment un travail d'ensemble et
c'est quelque chose de de kiffa chaque
mesure ce ce que se complètent et ja oui
il ya une certaine incohérence dans ce
qui mit donc je pense que c'est là le
danger
donc moi c'est pour ça que je trouve
plutôt intéressant que les propositions
référendum soit juste sur la paix contre
l'aspect constitutionnel etc en soit
rester là et puis que sur le reste
eh ben c'est sûr que là c'est à
l'exécutif à qui pour le coup un peu au
pied du mur et moi c'est pour ça que je
demande j'ai entendu delphine batho je
crois hier aux questions d'actualité qui
demandait clairement à ce que un texte
qui reprennent l'ensemble
ben justement de cette cohérence soit
déposer très rapidement au parlement et
que pour le coup le parlement prenne la
main elle demandé même est ce que ça
soit fait dès dès cet été
moi en tout cas je dis je dis chiche et
je suis plutôt partant pour ça on est
plusieurs élus à avoir signé un courrier
qui va être envoyée manuel macron pour
aller dans le dans le même sens et un
courrier en plus ce trans partisan pour
dire allons-y maintenant il faut passer
à l'acte et il faut qu'on débatte alors
bien sûr qu'après il y aura le travail
parlementaire qui arrivera m'at-il dit
mr tout l'enjeu aussi et bien dans ce
moment de résolution c'est de ne pas
reproduire ce qui s'est passé avec les
gilet jaune en imposant d'en haut des
règles ou des taxes aux citoyens au nom
de l'environnement lorsque vous voyez
mon le débat quand même qui émergent et
à l'issue de la convention citoyenne
vous êtes optimiste sur le fait
d'arriver à réconcilier les citoyens
avec cette question et je pense que
c'est très important ce que vous venez
de dire c'est dire que les propositions
de la convention elles ne peuvent être
comprises que si on les voit comme un
socle un socle qui deux mesures et
d'actions qui dessine un nouveau modèle
de société qui prend en compte l'urgence
climatique et sociale
parce que quand on prend juste quelques
phrases là comme vous le faites pas ce
que vous n'avez pas trop le choix
finalement 140 à propos des 600 pages on
ne voit pas tout ce qui est proposé
derrière en termes de justice sociale
quand on dit obligation de rénovation
des bâtiments
ça fait 30 ans que par l'incitation et
ça y est c'est pour ça que les citoyens
ont atterri à la conclusion il faut
obliger mais par contre on oblige pas
sans permettre à chacun de le faire
correctement donc on permet d'avoir des
prêts à taux zéro un reste à charge pour
les plus modestes qui est quasi nulle ça
c'est extrêmement important ça se
retrouve dans tout
leur proposition parce que ce qu'il
propose c'est pas juste des
interdictions des taxes des obligations
c'est un monde dans lequel on vit mieux
on mange mieux on respire mieux et c'est
ça qui veulent dessiner je pense que
c'est là dessus que doit supporter le
débat c'est quel modèle de société on
veut c'est peut-être pour ça que ça fait
peur à certains
jean-philippe d'un seul ça vous fait
peur d'ouvrir ce débat sur notre modèle
de société
c'est à dire une onde ou à manger
quelle est la température de notre
appartement quel mode de transport on
doit prendre et on voudrait aussi nous
imposer des risques sans commune mesure
avec cette loi écocide sur la l'a
finalement les pénalités en fonction
d'une sorte d'arc écocide qui finalement
ne veut pas dire grand chose qui serait
interprétée ce qui veut dire que ça met
tout le monde en péril tout ça est très
liberticide
tout cela est très réelle liberté m je
veux dire par rapport à ce qui vient
d'être dit c'est déjà le cas en fait on
nous dicte déjà ce qu'on doit manger on
nous dit que déjà de manière dont on
doit se déplacer
je prends un exemple 80 pour 10 % des
aides sont par exemple sur l'agriculture
traditionnelle et une toute petite
partie sur l'agriculture bio donc
donc en fait c'est plutôt ce qui a été
dit c'est vraiment une réorientation
mais en fait les choix sont bien dicter
et c'est là où je pense on sert à
quelque chose et où on fait de la
politique
alors maintenant se pose aussi une
question c'est est ce qu'il faut aller
plus loin pérenniser une assemblée pour
faire entendre la voix citoyenne
c'est ce que proposait le
constitutionnaliste dominique rousseau
dans une tribune publiée dans le monde
il dit pour des confiné et la france
politique il faut reconnaître la
compétence des citoyens qu'est ce que
vous en pensez jérôme bignon est ce que
ça pourrait être pérennisée est ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer une assemblée
citoyenne alors là en l'occurrence
dominique rousseau proposait bien la fin
du conseil d'état remplacée par une
assemblée citoyenne mais ce que on peut
aller plus loin dans cette réflexion
c'est un sujet où on peut pas répondre
par oui ou par non
c'est un peu compliqué cent cinquante
propositions ne peuvent pas donner lieu
à un texte de loi
enfin il faut avoir une très une
gigantesque méconnaissance du travail
parlementaire et du travail
réglementaire pour imaginer un instant
que ces 150 propositions je prends en
reprenant l'exemple de évoquée par jean
philippe delsol sur le logement
évidemment on souhaite tous avoir des
logements isolé le problème c'est que ce
que disent les citoyens c'est que c'est
une priorité pour eux qu'on se donne les
moyens juridiques financiers les
législatifs ou réglementaires pour parce
que pour une raison simple c'est que
c'est plus confortable ça va de soi mais
c'est deuxièmement vous très intéressant
parce que ça consomme
ça évite de vous envoyer du gaz
carbonique donc dans le sol dans le
bilan le dans l'air donc il faut et ça
c'est urgent et donc c'est plutôt je
pense une a dit des indications de
priorités qui sont donnés par les par
les citoyens parce que ce sont des
priorités qui nous permettent
d'atteindre des objectifs de 2030 et
2050 si on le fait pas
ça veut dire que l'urgence climatique
n'est pas reconnue et quelque part cet
ensemble de 2,2 de textes qu'il y en
aura d'autres parce qu'il ya d'autres
gens qui ont des idées que les citoyens
les parlementaires aussi ont des idées
on arrivera on n'arrivera pas à
atteindre 7,7 y cette histoire
climatique en 2030 et en 2050 à la
neutralité carbone en 2050 2050 c'est
dans 30 ans ça va aller une vitesse
fulgurante moi je serai plus là pour le
voir malheureusement
j'aimerais vivre assez long pour le voir
le jus mais si on commence pas très très
vite à y aller avec des mesures de ce
type
c'est aussi une façon de faire prendre
conscience à l'ensemble de la population
que c'est pas seulement les
parlementaires qui décide il faut que la
population s'y mettent et pousse en même
temps que le comité citoyen je pense
qu'il ya un vrai il ya une espèce de
dande effet d'entraînement qui est utile
mais faut pas rêver qu'on va faire un
texte avec les 150 plusieurs saynètes en
images
50 mais par exemple sur l'urgence il ya
quand même c'est que ce matin en
commission à l'assemblée nationale avait
deux textes sur l'amélioration des
performances thermiques qui ont été
rejetées quoi et qui était exactement
des éléments qui se retrouvent justement
dans 750 go conditions voilà c'est à
dire que nous donc on voit que encore il
ya encore du il ya encore du boulot
quand même du boulot et bien voilà pour
le programme est donc on rappelle que
vous serez reçus par emmanuel macron un
gain la semaine prochaine au lendemain
du résultat des municipales merci à tous
les cadres d'avoir participé à ce débat
merci m'at-il dit mr merci guillaume
gontard merci jérôme bignon et merci
jean philippe delsol dans une demi-heure
le temps fort de cette émission les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement il
va y avoir des questions sur la
convention citoyenne dont on vient de
parler notamment l'inscription de
l'ecosite dans la loi plusieurs
interrogations sur la relance économique
mais aussi des questions sur le climat
social le chômage les licenciements qui
s'annonce dans cette phase d'après
qu'ovide à ce sujet le monde d'après
va-t-il ressembler au monde d'avant en
tout cas emmanuel macron n'a pas
abandonné ses idées de réforme réforme
des retraites ou encore assurance
chômage c'est ce que nous a expliqué
hier est bien le patron des sénateurs
socialistes patrick kanner on écoute
j'espérais qu'il nous dirait et qu'il
abandonnerait purement seulement
l'assurance chômage non elle sera
adaptée que la réforme des retraites
serait abrogé nom va se poursuivre
peut-être une autre forme là aussi mais
elle va se poursuivre et j'espérais
beaucoup qui nous donne des réponses sur
la fiscalité comme étant un levier de
justice sociale et là aussi c'était un
nom très clair comme d'ailleurs il a dit
dans son discours récent à la télévision
donc le changement de cap il est plutôt
à 360 degrés c'est à dire qu'on revient
au point de départ très très
concrètement la crise est une parenthèse
elle aura des conséquences sociales très
lourde mais je n'ai pas ressenti chez le
président malgré le constat qu'il y aura
de la dureté sociale dans notre pays je
n'ai pas senti une volonté de modifier
sa ligne politique
donc nous sommes devant un gouvernement
de droite libérale qui va poursuivre son
chemin et
combien quels sont les résultats voilà
pour cette interview de patrick kanner
interviewé hier on va parler donc de ce
qui se dessine pour la praye pandémie
avec deux invités sur ce plateau monique
lubin bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice ps des landes et vous êtes
membre du conseil d'orientation des
retraites les retraites c'est un sujet
qui va nous intéresser puisque
manifestement il est encore au programme
des manuels macro est avec nous
également sur ce plateau jean marc
gabouty bonjourbonjour vice-président du
sénat sénateurs rds de la haute-vienne
manic lubin première question pour vous
ce que nous dit patrick kanner c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de changement de
logiciel la réforme des retraites celle
de l'assurance chômage sont maintenues
mais elles seront adaptés c'est ce qu'a
dit le président de la république
peut-être déçu alors je ne sais pas si
déçu d'abord sur les retraites ont déjà
sur les routes je ne sais pas si déçu
c'est le mot puisque je n'attendais pas
vraiment de changement sur les retraites
j'attends de voir puisque pour l'instant
il n'y a pas d'annoncés précises et nous
avons interrogé monsieur qui est très
skis qui n'a pas été en situation de
nous dire si réellement il y aurait une
reprise du projet hilaire de dieu manuel
macron maintenu mais adapté donc oui
alors ça mais ça m'interroge beaucoup ça
m'interroge beaucoup et je me demande
pourquoi on va remettre sur le tapis
maintenant un projet de loi qui est
particulièrement anxiogène
je pense que ça n'est pas le moment oui
jean marc gabouty est ce que c'est le
moment la réforme des retraites bien sûr
elle a occasionné bien les grandes
mobilisations dont on se rappelle en fin
d'année dernière
est ce que c'est le moment dans ce
moment d'après cogne vide de remettre et
bien une réforme qui lèverait à cliver
les français alors le moment je ne sais
pas moi je le crois que le président de
la république est un réformateur
il entend continuer les réformes et je
trouve que ça c'est très bien on peut
pas m je dirais le couvercle sur la
marmite qui bout et puis laisser sortir
simplement les cubes il faut il faut
traiter effectivement les problèmes
probablement les traités différemment au
vu de ce qui s'est passé pour le coc
bible et surtout les conséquences
économiques de cela je prends l'exemple
on n'est pas sur les retraites mais sur
l'assurance chômage mais on peut pas
traiter le problème aujourd'hui comme il
a été traité il ya sept huit mois il
faut changer sa façon de voir le
problème c'est ce que dit d'ailleurs
également le rapporteur du projet de loi
de retraites à l'assemblée nationale
alain guillaumin gouffier chat regardez
ce qu'il dit il dit vu la tension dans
le pays nous ne devons pas nous orienter
vers des solutions dur qui recréerait du
conflit social la réforme ne doit pas
être un sujet de crispation mais
d'avancées sociales
ça ce sont quand même des paroles que
vous entendez monique lubin ça peut
redessiner aussi le visage de la réforme
des retraites alors ça ne serait pas
dessiner le visage de la réforme ça
serait faire une réforme totalement
différente parce que pour l'instant de
ce que j'ai pu voir dans le projet de
réforme il n'y avait pas beaucoup
d'avancées sociales il y avait d'abord
ce que je considère moi comme étant
plutôt des reculades sur l'âge de départ
à la retraite et même si on enlève le
spectre de ce recul
bon il y a un projet de retraite à
points dont je n'ai toujours pas compris
ce qu'il apporterait de plus aux
retraités
vous n'avez toujours pas compris on va
demander en tout cas et bien claude
malhuret lui ce qu'il a pensé et bien de
cet entretien cre ont eu les présidents
de groupe hier avec le président de la
république qui est à votre micro steve
installe des conférences oui d'un claude
malhuret
bonjour vous étiez donc à cette réunion
hier avec emmanuel macron comment vous
l'avez senti l'état déterminé et en
changeait transformé avec cette crise
sanitaire pourrait coûter
je les trouvais ça va peut-être vous
décevoir mais j'ai trouvé parfaitement
comme à son habitude même plutôt surpris
de le voir
malgré tout les tous les problèmes la
crise sanitaire et ce qui se profile à
la rentrée
comme d'habitude est tout à fait
effectivement déterminé comme vous le
dites
souriant et visiblement ci était stressé
il le cache est parfaitement bien parce
que voilà la réunion était décontractée
je dirais pas amicale y avait des
groupes avaient tous les groupes
politiques
mais elles étaient franches les gens on
s'est dit des uns et les autres qu'on
avait à se dire
elle était de temps en temps avec humour
voilà donc une commune un déjeuner comme
on a pu en faire déjà dans le passé mais
qui est pas barque et particulièrement
par le stress de la crise même si je
pense qu'il existe
vous avez dit déterminé détermine
notamment à faire passer cette réforme
des retraites qui suscite beaucoup
d'inquiétude alors lui on n'a pas la
réforme des retraites n'a pas été
le point essentiel de la discussion mais
il a été un point évidemment le
président de rappeler les deux
impératifs qui sont d'une part le fait
qu'il ya un problème financier
aujourd'hui et encore plus avec les
recettes qui vont diminuer dans du point
de vue du premier de la crise économique
et deuxièmement
besoin d'égalité d'équité
donc voilà il nous a pas donné de
calendrier nous avait dit exactement
mais ils pensent ils continuent penser
que lui devancé d'une réforme qui serait
affaire et sur le report des élections
vous ai parlé vous avez un oui mais le
report des élections dès qu'on parle du
report des élections
on entre dans la politique politicienne
lui explique que c'est un vrai problème
d'avoir la relance économique nécessaire
pour laquelle les régions et les
départements sont les principaux
donneurs d'ordre et par exemple pour le
btp c'est fondamental que les régions or
évidemment offert des élections au mois
de mars prochain
ça veut dire de plus avoir de d'action
des régions des départements pendant les
mois qui viennent alors que c'est au
moment donc c'est un peu c'est un sujet
qui peut se défendre mais il a bien
insisté sur le fait qu'il ne le ferait
qu'avec le consensus
généraliser et comme j'ai l'impression
qu'au consensus n'est pas là je jure que
je change de calories on verra ça merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à mes questions
claude malhuret
c'est à vous timbre retour en plateau
merci beaucoup aux steve alors bon
c'était pas de points essentiels les
retraites mais tout de même
emmanuel macron dit qu'il ya un problème
financier et un besoin d'équité il est
vrai que le problème financier
l'état assure endetté avec la crise de
l'après qu'ovide c'est un vrai problème
cela est maintenant j'en ai gagné il ya
un problème de jeudi rêver qui m'ont ya
un problème financier aussi un problème
de nos systèmes de systèmes de retraite
on veut garder tous on dirait c'est cet
accord une retraite par par répartition
moi je pense qu'il faudra reprendre ce
dossier alors ce qu'il faut le reprendre
en septembre peut-être pas c'est
peut-être pas en septembre en octobre
c'est peut-être pas le meilleur moment
mais il faudra assez rapidement le
reprendre et je comprends que le
président de la république ne
l'abandonnent pas c'était un élément
important de son programme
ce qui veut pas dire que j'étais
systématiquement favorable à tout ce qui
était proposé moins cher est favorable
au régime à points qui permet au niveau
justice d'intégrer tout un tas de
particularités je dirais pour les
carrières interrompues pour les familles
ayant des enfants pour les périodes de
chômage pour la pénibilité on peut tout
un je dirais à amener sur un système à
points par bonification des points
techniquement c'est un c'est un bon
système
ensuite par contre je n'étais pas
favorable à ce niveau parce que je pense
que dans la construction à terme un
avoir un âge avec un système à points
c'est quelque chose qui est incompatible
pour moi et en pratique ça pénaliser
certains certains retraités turbul
nombre de points suffisants et on leur
disait comme vous avez comme vous
n'allez pas jusqu'à l'âge pivot
on va vous faire une décote ont quitté
ce que le gouvernement a reconnu
d'ailleurs qu'il est profondément
anachronique et injuste donc je suis
assez proche des positions constructives
de deux de la cfdt de l'unsa peut-être
monique lubin à ce qu il ya maintenant
tout de même urgence à réformer le
système lorsqu'on voit bien le problème
de la dette qui n'était pas si urgent
avant le coc vide et maintenant on a
véritablement un problème de
surendettement de l'état on entend déjà
à droite eric woerth kids id il faut
vraiment relever l'âge de départ à la
retraite face à cette urgence bon
écouter de toute façon ceux qui
considèrent depuis le début qu'il faut
retarder l'âge de la retraite trouveront
forcément durant la crise de l'après
coco vide de trouveront forcément les
bonnes raisons de réformer le système
des retraites donc ce que dit eric
woerth il le parle il le pense depuis
toujours et pour lui c'est l'occasion
qui fait le larron
par contre je pense que ce ne serait
absolument pas sérieux d'entamer une
réforme des retraites maintenant parce
que effectivement les comptes sont dans
le rouge
mais je participe à une réunion du cor
la semaine dernière ils sont dans le
rouge à l'orientation vrai du conseil
d'orientation des retraites pardon ils
sont dans le rouge après 2 - mais on ne
peut absolument pas extrapoler et savoir
ce qui va se passer
hier j'entendais aussi lors d'une
audition que finalement les rentrées
sociales ont été nettement meilleures
que prévu au mois de juin
donc attendons attendons de voir avant
tout état de cause la réforme telle
qu'elle était prévue aujourd'hui ne
trouve absolue alors elle avait déjà pas
son sens à mes yeux si ce n'est un sens
purement idéologique et elle le trouve
encore moins aujourd'hui
autre réforme suspendu par la pandémie
la réforme de l'assurance chômage
elle devait entrer en application en
france son deuxième volet il ya déjà
plusieurs semaines elle a été mise entre
parenthèses mais elle doit s'appliquer a
dit le président de la république et
cela malgré le contexte contexte plutôt
de fragilisation sociale les plans de
licenciements qui sont annoncés écoutez
par exemple bien les salariés de nokia à
lannion qui réagissent bien aux plans de
suppression de 1200 33 postes en france
on nous a annoncé que la moitié des
postes étaient supprimés sur notre site
à lannion donc ses 400 postes sur 762 je
crois donc
le sentiment c'est que tout le monde est
abasourdi en fait parce que nokia a des
décide qu'il faut à peu près plus de 500
employés donc c'est pratiquement rayé de
la carte en fait cette année donc ça a
été un choc un choc terrible
on a pris ça c'est une catastrophe parce
que on s'y attendait pas les résultats
économiques sont bons il ya de
l'activité
on demande aux salariés de travailler le
week-end et d'organiser leurs vacances
pour être toujours présent donc cesser
complètement incompréhensible est
complètement aberrant
les résultats économiques sont bons et
malgré cela et bien nokia se lance dans
ce plan de suppressions de postes jean
marc gabouty votre réaction je précise
qu'en fait c'est parce que nokia avait
dit lorsqu'il avait racheté
'alcatel-lucent indices étaient engagés
à préserver les emplois pendant deux ans
et désormais il est libéré de cet
engagement et du coup voilà ce plan de
suppressions
oui mais s'il ya de l'activité
finalement résultats économiques on peut
ne pas comprendre et je comprends tout à
fait la réaction des salariés vous aurez
toujours dans ces périodes des groupes
avec des actionnaires en plano nîmes on
n'est pas dans le milieu des pme ou de
grandes entreprises même familiale
française qui profitent de la situation
pour s'organiser
différemment en respectant leur
engagement uniquement pour que ne soit
pas remis en cause les aides financières
qu'ils ont reçu et je m'engage
personnellement même si j'ai une origine
chez des entreprises je dénonce tout à
fait ce genre de comportement ensuite
simplement un mot si vous voulez je
crois que l'on parle souvent de réformes
sociales et le problème économique je
pense qu'il faut pas dissocier les deux
l'économique et le social c'est quelque
chose qui va qui va vraiment de père et
il faut avoir un raisonnement sur les
retraites sur le chômage sur sur le
partage de la richesse sur les
conditions d'embauché etc
il faut avoir une vision il faut
vraiment avoir une vision globale et ne
pas compartimentée parce que les deux
sont liés aujourd'hui ce qu'on a besoin
c'est quoi c'est pas de travailler plus
c'est d'abord d'avoir suffisamment de
travail
voilà je veux dire qu'il faut être il
faut être précis on voit ces débats qui
est en train de monter sur le travail et
puis il faut que le pays travaille plus
mais individuellement beaucoup
d'entreprises qu'elle demande c'est de
pouvoir travailler à 80 90 % à 100 % de
leurs capacités demande pas travailler à
120 elles sont à 70 voilà il faut avoir
il faut aussi être réaliste dans ce
domaine monique les bains vous
acquiescez à ce que vient de dire à jean
marc gabouty et puis votre réaction
aussi et bien à ce plan de suppressions
d'emplois chez nokia alors que disent
les syndicalistes et bien l'entreprise
fonctionne ça en dit long sur le
fonctionnement de certains grands
groupes comme vient de le dire mans mon
collègue jean marc gabouty on peut pas
bien évidemment remettre en cause tous
les entrepreneurs de france mais là on
est vraiment dans un modèle que l'on
connaît déjà et dont on pouvait espérer
qu'ils avaient qu il allait trouver
quelque part sa fin j'espère simplement
que la crise qu vide ne sera pas un
prétexte pour que se multiplient ce
genre de plans sociaux
oui et dans ce contexte du coût de la
préco vide
jean marc gabouty ne pensez vous pas
qu'il faut une assurance chômage plus
protectrice alors que cette crise risque
d'être très difficile on se rappelle
quand il ya eu la réforme de l'assurance
chômage parce qu'on disait bon ben il
faut on accompagne le fait qu'il y ait
de plus en plus d'emplois que l'économie
redémarre etc mais là c'est moi j'étais
gt gt d'accord avec le gouvernement pour
aller dans cette direction dans une
période on était descendu un taux de
chômage de 8% et on avait l'espoir
d'aller vers 7 %
donc là il fallait faire mais on n'est
plus dans la même situation si vous
voulez c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on
peut faire la réforme mais il faut il
faut il faut assouplir beaucoup de
choses c'est à dire que notamment sur le
temps travaillé au cours d un de la
période de référence qui avait été qui
avait été singulièrement réduit de six
mois à quatre mois je crois ensuite la
reprise dès la reprise leur chargement
au niveau des changements des taux de
chômage qui avait également été je
dirais travail alors si vous voulez dans
une période où vous avez des offres
d'emploi qui ne sont pas satisfaites
peut-être pour des raisons de formation
d'ailleurs ce pas uniquement pour des
uniquement des raisons de mauvaise
volonté il faut inciter les personnes à
travailler aujourd'hui les personnes
vont être au chômage sont des personnes
qui subissent qui ont envie de
travailler mais beaucoup on voit dans
différents plans sociaux ou même dans la
môme embauche etc sont des gens qui sont
victimes sont pas des gens qui se
laissent un petit peu allez donc on ne
peut pas raisonner exactement de la même
manière lorsqu'on va vers un taux de
chômage à 12 % que lorsqu'on va vers un
taux de chômage à 7%
donc il faut adapter il faut
probablement faire la réforme l'armée
devant les partenaires sociaux en disant
bon on était dans cette direction
maintenant il faut remettre à plat et
rediscuter quelque chose qui paraissent
plus d'équité il ya des discussions
derrière entre muriel pénicaud
actuellement et les partenaires sociaux
et vous monique lubin vous demander à
aller plus loin
moi je demande la suppression de cette
de cette réforme qui qui me paraissait
déjà parfaitement injuste et qui
maintenant s'avère carrément inique et
je vais d'ailleurs en profiter pour
citer un exemple concret de ceux qui
essaient de faire parler d'eux en ce
moment ce que l'on appelle les extras je
ne sais pas si vous avez vu des
reportages sur ces personnes qui
travaille dans l'événementiel alors
aussi bien culturelles que familial j'ai
envie de dire lorsque vous organisez un
mariage où sont des gens qui qui ont
fait le choix de travailler sur des
petits contrats et qui mènent leur vie
professionnelle de cette façon et qui
aujourd'hui compte tenu des modalités de
de l'assurance chômage se retrouve au
rsa quasiment immédiatement et plonge
des gens dans la misère
c'est un exemple parmi d'autres mais
cette réforme il faut réellement
maintenant la supprimer et
éventuellement effectivement voir
comment on peut avancer pour tous ceux
qui vont perdre leur emploi
ce qu'il faut pas oublier que le rsa
c'est la charge des départements va pas
amorcé aussi ce débat maintenant mais la
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement on les voit dans ce couloir
et effectivement c'est dans une dizaine
de minutes maintenant
jean marc gabouty on entend et dahmani
cubain vous vous demandez et bien
complètement la fin de cette réforme
mais et sur ceux sur ce point sur la
question du durcissement du calcul de
l'allocation pour les plus précaires
c'est vrai que c'est un grand sujet
quand on voit qu'aujourd'hui et bien
justement les plus précaires avec la
crise sont les premiers à être tombé
directement au chômage c'est pas c'est
pas uniquement s'est pas uniquement
d'ailleurs des salariés c'est parfois
des travailleurs indépendants sont des
professions les plus fragiles sont
descendu d'un cran les plus fragiles
alors oui en même temps ils ont inondé
certains ont des possibilités de rebond
peut être plus aisé de reconversion et
sais pas s'ils ont ils en ont fait un
choix
mais en termes de salariés dont nos
d'abord les problèmes de métier ensuite
zones géographiques
il ya des problèmes de niveau de
formation donc effectivement ambitions
cumul des handicaps dans ces différentes
catégories
oui c'est 17 vient ça devient difficile
moi je suis prend un système incitatif
mais pas injuste c'est pour ça que je
dis aujourd'hui on peut pas faire la
réforme telle qu'elle a été prévu alors
on a fait pas et on recommence aux deux
choses où on dit on la remet sur la
table et on la modifie profondément je
me moi j'ai pas de il faut être
pragmatique froid en la matière mais
c'est vrai que la situation actuelle
parce que ce que simplement ce que je
voudrais dire je pense qu'on nous
annonce des chiffres si les en termes de
pertes d'emplois alors si ces pertes
d'emplois salariés etc
si on n'a pas tous les mêmes références
mais le niveau de chômage quand on dit
on va vite cent mille pertes d'emplois
mignon on est un million pour mars avril
avec la suppression dans l'ensemble des
contrats courts etc sûr mais on va vers
les 3 millions enfin voilà il faut il
faut être qu'il faut être aussi tout se
passe bien sur le plan économique assez
si c'est pas catastrophique en valais 3
millions parce que si vous allez à 12 %
de taux de chômage que vous avez
forcément je dirais 50% de plus de
chômeurs et si vous prenez les
catégories a et b b vous prenez 50% que
vous êtes à trois millions de chômeurs
supplémentaires en fin d'année et sans
que ce soit une catastrophe économique
mais sur plan social c'est vous et c'est
compliqué c'est une catastrophe sociale
3 millions de chômeurs supplémentaires
monique lubin juste le il ya des
discussions actuellement avec les muriel
pénicaud et apparemment le gouvernement
est prêt à revenir sur un certain nombre
de points sur la réforme de l'assurance
chômage mais un point sur lequel ils ne
veulent pas revenir c'est la question la
dégressivité de toute façon en règle
générale je trouve totalement incongru
qu'un moment où comme viennent de
l'expliquer clairement mon collègue à un
moment où des millions de gens vont se
retrouver des milliers de gens des
centaines de gens vont se retrouver sans
emploi
on imagine aujourd'hui des réformes qui
amoindriront leur droit enfin je je je
ne je ne comprends pas puisque je
voudrais dire aussi c'est que c'est
totalement opposés à ce qu'a dit le
président de la république lors de son
allocution du mois d'avril
il a dit clairement qu'il avait compris
un certain nombre de messages et qu'ils
allaient se préoccuper de ceux qui
avaient été en avant pendant cette crise
qui sont en général les plus mal perçu
et les plus mal payés
aujourd'hui ces gens là vont
certainement payé un lourd tribut à la
crise et ce qui est annoncé et
totalement contraire à ce qui a été dit
ce jour là parce que hier presque marins
portés et patrick kanner il n'a pas été
fait état d'améliorations mais plutôt de
continuité dans les réformes sur le même
ton pas de changement de l'assurance
chômage
il faut - il nourrit il faut au moins la
reporter on peut pas la mettre en
application à l'automne au 1er janvier
il faut au moins la reporter de plus
d'un an je les bases peut-être
différente mais pendant que le chômage
augmente il faut pas la faire
eh bien merci à beaucoup jean marc
gabouty merci beaucoup moins et qui
vient d'avoir participé à ce débat on
continue à parler bien de cette question
du
chômage des vagues de licenciements le
groupe communiste va d'ailleurs
interrogé le gouvernement sur bien ces
suppressions d'emplois dont on parlait à
l'instant chez nokia éric bocquet
sénateur communiste du nord est à votre
micro steve oui précisément éric bocquet
bonjour on a donc appris que j'ai eus
nokia france allait supprimer 1233 poste
en france quelle est votre réaction
nokia pour parler nos gars oui mais
alors écoutez nous qu'il ya il ya quatre
ans à racheter la filiale alcatel lucent
avec un engagement de préserver l'emploi
engagements pris avec le ministre de
l'économie de l'époque un certain
emmanuel macron je crois on en est au
quatrième plan de licenciement dans ce
groupe très sans emploi effectivement
concernés sur deux sites 2019 sont 2
milliards de dividendes qui ont été
distribués 5 milliards depuis
l'acquisition de 2016
on est encore une fois sur l'application
stricte d'une logique financière puisque
je lisais un article de capital
remontant à il ya un an où on voyait que
l'entreprise marchait bien
avait augmenté ses ventes de 8% son
action avait pris et 6% de valeurs les
derniers temps est l'objectif de la
direction à l'époque c'était une
rentabilité comprise entre 12 et 16 % en
2020 donc à mon avis le chiffre n'est
pas atteint ça n'est pas suffisant aux
yeux des actionnaires
on est dans un cas ce sont les salariés
encore une fois qu'ils vont payer la
facture
au nom des actionnaires c'est absolument
inacceptable que dit l'entreprise c'est
qu'elle s'était engagée sur deux ans les
deux ans se sont écoulés et donc
maintenant elle a un peu les mains
libres par rapport notamment à s'est
engagé autour des mains libres c'est un
peu rapide par ce conduit une époque
quand même le développement de la 5g va
être exponentielle ça devient un outil
de communication on l'a vu on l'a vu
avec la crise dans laquelle on sait pas
on s'est trouvés pendant deux mois avec
le télétravail etc
donc il ya un marché gigantesque à
l'échelle du monde on est dans une
compétition entre les grands ericsson
nokia etc
on peut pas justifier le sacrifice de
milliers d'emplois pour cette raison là
précisément on annonce un repli du pib
d'environ 11% pour certaines et comment
on hésite la début d'une débâcle sociale
oui les gars de l'argent public là
l'état s'est engagé fortement
donc on peut pas accepter que les
milliards les dizaines de milliards
versés au pot ca va accompagner
simplement les licenciements et la case
une industrie on parle de relocalisation
on parle de redévelopper le tissu
industriel français voient là une
occasion d'en faire la preuve on peut
pas accepter cette cette décision de
nokia
mais en dehors précisément du cac nokia
france comment on évite des
licenciements massifs qu'on annonce pour
la rentrée réorienter l'argent vers
l'économie réelle
on est aujourd'hui sous la tutelle des
marchés financiers les états les grands
groupes on va nous accabler de la dette
donc on va payer la crise par les
licenciements par l'appauvrissement des
populations et on va être condamné à
rembourser la dette à perpétuité il faut
sortir de cette logique financière du
haut en bas de notre économie
petite dernière question on a appris qu
emmanuel macron que l'élysée entendait
bien poursuivre cette réforme des
retraites qui avait été suspendue quelle
est votre réaction qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
je suis scandalisé cette réforme des
retraites ne faisait pas l'unanimité
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
la bataille de l'opinion n'a pas été
gagnée par le gouvernement la crise
duclos vie d'être intervenu pour tous
suspendre mais monsieur macron n'oublie
pas pourquoi il est là il est en mission
parler soutenu par les gens les marchés
financiers dont je parlais l'on choisit
l'on construit l'ont fait élire et il
est en mission pour faire avancer le
marché dans cette société donc remettre
en avant la retraite franchement alors
que les gens aspirent à mieux vivre
alors que on est sur la question du
partage des richesses c'est tout à fait
inacceptable
merci beaucoup monsieur ben ok je vous
laisse rejoindre l'hémicycle les
questions au gouvernement vont bientôt
débuter et âme
oui merci beaucoup et steve pour cette
interview autre sujet qui va marquer
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement on en a parlé au début de
cette émission c'est l'inscription du
crime déco side dans la loi c'est une
des propositions de la convention
citoyenne c'était aussi celle du groupe
socialiste au sénat
il y avait notamment une proposition de
loi portée par jérôme durain et steve
justement bien vous êtes avec le
sénateur socialiste alors que nous
sommes à quelques minutes de la séance
de questions d'actualité et jérôme
durain va poser une question sur ce
sujet oui jérôme durain bonjour vous
allez poser une question sur le sujet du
crime déco side la convention citoyenne
qu'elle propose que cette mesure soit
proposée aux français vous y êtes
favorable j'imagine bien sûr nous sommes
le premier groupe parlementaire groupe
socialiste au sénat avoir proposé cette
nouvelle incrimination pour mettre fin à
l'impunité sur les crimes
environnementaux les plus graves
volontaires intentionnel on nous a dit
c'est une bonne idée mais passez votre
chemin
les députés socialistes ont répété
l'opération dans une version un peu
différente on leur a dit la même chose
aujourd'hui la convention citoyenne pour
climat propose à nouveau ce crime
descossy donc on attend la réponse du
gouvernement
mais précisément dont il y avait cette
proposition des sénateurs socialistes
elle avait été refusée à l'époque
vous pensez que
il ya on peut elle peut passer cette
fois ci et comment sous quelle forme
la question c'est pas tant le fond de
l'ecosite qui mérite qu'on s'y intéresse
que la méthode on voit qu'on a une
demande forte dans la société émergente
un sujet qui mobilise des militants et
puis des simples citoyens qui disent on
en a marre que la planète soit abîmée
par des gens qui font n'importe quoi
ça paraît pas si compliqué et je
comprends pas pour y a eu un entêtement
comme ça dans le parcours législatif des
deux propositions de loi donc maintenant
il faut ouvrir droit à une réponse
favorable pour que ça rentre dans notre
droit pénal et qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui critiquent à la fois
la méthode et les propositions de cette
convention citoyenne
écoutez on peut pas dire à la fois qu'il
faut que ce soit radicale et sans filtre
et qu'on a besoin d'un grand élan
démocratique d'évoquer emmanuel macron
emmanuel lacroix évidemment et puis
ensuite bétonner derrière en disant non
ça c'est trop difficile ça c'est trop
radical c'est trop compliqué ça on a
déjà fait ça ça existe déjà c'est pas
possible donc soit on est dans une
démarche est sincère
si on ne l'est pas messi a pas de
sincérité il peut y avoir la frustration
il peut y avoir le sentiment de mépris
et il peut faire de la colère donc
attention joue pas avec la démocratie on
joue pas que la citoyenneté comme ça on
évoque la possibilité d'un référendum à
choix multiples un genre de qcm qui
serait proposé aux citoyens vous y est
favorable
moi je sais que ce que je souhaite c'est
qu'on fasse du bon travail en écoutant
ce que les citoyens nous ont dit et en
ayant des mesures applicables il s'agit
pas simplement de faire de la com et de
ripoliner quelques mesures parmi les 7
49 qui ont été proposées il s'agit
d'avoir des choses applicable dans du
bon travail juridique et les
parlementaires que nous sommes nous
sommes disposés à aider le gouvernement
s'ils le souhaitent mais sur du fond
l'article 11 de la constitution précise
que le droit pénal est exclue du champ
référendaire or en l'occurrence le
l'infraction dont on parle serait inclus
dans ce dans le champ de ce référendum
comme en fait ces difficultés juridiques
ce qui m'intéresse moi c'est la volonté
politique donc si on veut que krim
d'ecaussinnes entre dans notre droit
pénal
on y arrivera parce qu'elle volonté
politique le reste c'est une question de
mise en oeuvre c'est moins important
toujours sur ce thème certaines ong
saluent cette proposition de la
convention mais estime que ce crime
descossy tels que définis par la
convention est très restreint ne
concernerait que très peu d'acteurs
finalement sur le terrain coûté une fois
les plus loin il faut encore on aura
toujours des gens des observateurs des
militants des juristes pour nous dire
c'est trop s'est passé on l'avait vu ici
au débat en mai le 2019
l'essentiel c'est qu'on avance qu'on
commence à poser une première pierre on
améliorer ensuite le remercie jérôme
durain je vous laisse à rejoindre
l'hémicycle parce que la séance est donc
ouverte on va suivre donc ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement on se
retrouve juste après sur public sénat a
tout de suite lors du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
je vous remercie d'excuser l'absence du
président du sénat qui assiste en ce
moment même à la séance plénière au
cours de laquelle le conseil économique
et social et environnemental qu'il a
consultés en application de l'article 70
de la constitution présente le projet
d'avis intitulé la prévention et la
réduction du chômage de longue durée
dans une perspective d'action
territorial pour le respect des règles
sanitaires
il vous est demandé de laisser un siège
vide entre deux sièges occupés ou de
porter un masque si ce n'est pas le cas
je rappelle que l'hémicycle fait l'objet
d'un nettoyage et d'une désinfection
avant et après chaque séance les micros
seront désinfectés
après chaque intervention j'invite
chacune et chacun à veiller au respect
des distances de sécurité
je rappelle également que les sorties de
la salle des séances d'euros
exclusivement s'effectuer par les portes
situées au pourtour de l'hémicycle je
vous rappelle que la séance est
retransmise en direct sur public
senna et sur notre site internet au nom
du bureau du sénat
j'appelle chacun de vous mes chers
collègues a observé au cours de nos
échanges l'une des valeurs essentielles
du sénat le respect qu'il s'agisse du
respect des uns et des autres ou celui
du temps de parole et la parole est à
monsieur jérôme bignon pour le groupe
les indépendants république et
territoires
je recommence la boîte à outils de notre
mécano démocratique s'est enrichi de 25
avril 2019 d'un nouvel outil la
convention citoyenne
après plusieurs mois de travail 150
citoyens tirés au sort ont adopté 149
propositions pour changer la société
cette assemblée citoyenne est confortée
dans sa légitimité par l'histoire la
plus ancienne d'athènes à montesquieu
rousseau
elle est renforcée par le sérieux et
l'implication dans le travail accompli
que l'on soit d'accord ou pas avec les
propositions
elle ne se substitue pas aux organes de
notre démocratie parlementaire mais
contribue à nourrir leur réflexion et
éventuellement leurs actions certaines
mesures intéressantes met en exergue des
actions déjà engagées
d'autres portent un espoir qu'il faudra
traduire en actes adapté à la réalité
notre société ces travaux ne couvre
évidemment pas tous les champs
nécessaires et utiles à l'évolution
écologique vers laquelle notre pays
s'est engagé des propositions même les
plus pertinentes aux solutions acceptée
par une majorité de nos concitoyens
supportable par des minorités actives ou
encore financer
il peut y avoir un chemin souvent
chaotique
je pense à la question des pesticides à
la politique énergétique ou encore aux
moyens alloués à l'innovation
tout ça n'est pas toujours aussi facile
que certains le croient
l'europe doit également être partie
intégrante de ces avancées d'une part
parce qu'elle pourrait être l'échelon le
plus efficace qu sur des dossiers tels
qu'une taxe carbone aux frontières de
l'union
comme la convention l'a identifié
d'autre part qu'elle s'est emparé du
sujet climatique avec un paquet vert
messieurs qu'il va falloir maintenant
des gossier est agrémenté nous savons
tous que l'enjeu climatique et le défaut
de notre siècle
je suis persuadé que la solution est la
croissance décarbonés qui passe par
l'innovation
les nouvelles énergies et la recherche
et le développement madame la ministre
le gouvernement doit et va sûrement
écouter certaines propositions de la
convention
comment envisagez-vous d'intégrer ce
travail dans les stratégies et
engagements de la france pour remplir
nos engagements aux horizons 2030 et
2050 afin d'apporter une réponse durable
à ce défi global
merci la parole est à madame elisabeth
bornes ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire pour deux
minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vignon effectivement la
convention citoyenne pour le climat qui
avait été lancé par le président de la
république suite au grand débat national
m'a remis ses propositions
dimanche dernier cette convention je
voudrais rappeler ce sont 150 citoyens
tirés au sort
à l'image de notre pays des femmes des
hommes de 16 à 82 ans venant de tous les
territoires
ils ont travaillé avec beaucoup
d'exigence et d'engagement pendant neuf
mois et moi je voudrais d'abord le
rendre hommage
l'aboutissement de cette démarche c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour la démocratie et
pour l'écologie et je partage pleinement
la vision de la convention d'une
transformation écologique globale alors
beaucoup de propositions comme vous
l'avez souligné sont convergentes avec
les orientations que nous portons depuis
le début du quinquennat
d'autres vont créer du débat et c'est
normal le président de la république
avait demandé des propositions fortes à
la hauteur du défi climatique
le président les recevra va recevra des
représentants de la convention lundi
prochain et il pourra leur indiquer les
suites données à leurs propositions
certaines de ces propositions qui sont
finalisés ont vocation à être transmises
sans
filtre au parlement voire à référendum
cette étape est essentielle pour que la
démocratie délibérative s'articule avec
la démocratie représentative ou direct
d'autres propositions par ailleurs
doivent encore être approfondies
le président de la république l'a dit
nous devons penser une reconstruction
économique écologique et solidaire
les travaux de la convention sont au
coeur de ce projet merci monsieur
albéric de montgolfier pour le groupe
l'est républicain micro micro
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier disque dames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues le sénat a
voté vous le savez les deux premiers
plfr parce que ces deux plfr comportait
des mesures de soutien qui était
efficace qui était immédiate et en
revanche les interroge sur le troisième
plfr même si on peut regretter que les
mesures réglementaires n'était pas été
prise à temps je pense à la tva à 5,5
sur les tenues de protection dont
l'arrêté n'est toujours pas pris mais un
article d'un célèbre journal satirique
du mercredi va sans doute incité ce
texte à sortir dans la semaine comme
quoi mais je voudrais vous parler des du
prochain plfr qui constitue c'est vrai
une déception puisqu'il ne comporte
aucune mesure de relance
aucune mesure de relance alors que notre
pays connaît une chute de son pib de
plus de 11%
et si on se compare notamment à
l'allemagne l'allemagne a décidé des
mesures de relance vous l'avez vu à plus
de 50 milliards d'euros dont 9 milliards
pour l'hydrogène ce qui représente un
investissement de plus de 5 5% du pib
nous en sommes à 2 5% en france et se
paie ce plfr ne comporte notamment
aucune mesure pour relancer
l'investissement des entreprises
investissement qui a chuté de 20 à 25%
il ne comporte aucune mesure sur la
consommation des ménages
à part c'est vrai l'automobile il ne
comporte aucune mesure pour inciter les
collectivités à investir et je pense en
particulier aux retards pris dans les
cpe air au retard pris dans le très haut
débit qui ont des besoins considérables
et il ne comporte en effet aucune mesure
sur l'épargné des ménages 100 milliards
d'euros
au départ nous qui ont été confinés qui
devraient être des confiné qui pourrait
servir à investir ou à consommer donc
que nous sommes nombreux au sénat a
porté les uns et les autres des mesures
de relance dès maintenant et j'ai moi
même proposé des mesures fortes si nous
attendons comme peut-être le grenelle
prévoit le plf
le budget pour 2021 cela risque d'être
trop tard nous serons en quelque sorte
perdu six mois six mois par leur qu'elle
nous connaîtrons des défaillances
d'entreprises ma question est donc très
simple
pourquoi attendre pourquoi attendre pour
adopter des mesures de relance
indispensable merci madame agnès madame
agnès panière une hache est secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
et des finances pour répond pour deux
minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur albéric de montgolfier
vous avez raison cette crise allait
inédite on prévoit une baisse de notre
produit intérieur brut de 11 %
et comme vous le savez très rapidement
et vous le salut est d'ailleurs des
mesures d'urgence ont été prises quatre
mesures d'urgence qui ont permis de
venir au secours de notre économie
très rapidement je veux dire ici plutôt
plus rapidement que beaucoup de pays
européens je pense aux prêts garantis
par l'état par exemple ont été
disponibles
quelques jours après leur vote dans cet
hémicycle
je pense également au chômage partiel au
report de cotisations sociales et
fiscales est évidemment au fonds de
solidarité qui a été au rendez vous pour
les indépendants ces plans de soutien
ils sont aujourd'hui complète ses plans
de secours sont aujourd'hui complétée
par des plans de soutien et d'urgence
sectorielle car l'enjeu aujourd'hui
c'est de stabiliser notre économie et
c'est ce que nous faisons nous le
stabilisons avec 14 milliards d'euros de
financement n'est pas tout à fait
l'épaisseur du trait qui compléteront
les efforts déjà déployés pour porter à
18 milliards d'euros le plan pour le
tourisme 10 milliards d'euros le plan
automobile effectivement avec un soutien
l'électrification de notre flotte 15
milliards d'euros le plan aéronautique
qui porte un soutien r&d pour le futur
puisqu'il s'agit d'investir dans l'avion
décarbonés ou un milliard d'euros dans
la tête 400 millions d'euros pour la
culture autant de mesures qui sont
aujourd'hui nécessaires pour accompagner
les entreprises ils sont également
complété par des mesures transversales
je pense au remboursement anticipé de
créances de report en arrière des
déficits ou de primes à l'embauché
exceptionnelle pour les apprentis qui
sont autant de mesures extrêmement
attendu par les entreprises et par les
jeunes
ce plan sera prolongée par un plan de
relance vous l'avez dit ce plan de
relance nous y travaillons il visera à
accompagner la transformation de notre
économie
cette transformation nous en avons déjà
les éléments nous avons déjà des crédits
d'ailleurs disponible le sur
amortissement fiscal c'est un élément de
transformation rassurez vous nous ne
manquons pas aujourd'hui de carburant
pour avancer mais pour faire ce plan de
relance il faut stabiliser l'économie
avoir une vision sur l'économie mondiale
et nous serons au rendez vous dès
septembre merci les faire 4 la parole à
madame patricia sillinger pour le groupe
la république en marche
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres cher collègue
monsieur le ministre la crise sanitaire
économique que notre pays a connus est
aussi une crise humaine et sociale
les dispositifs mis en place tels que le
fonds de garantie ou le dispositif de
chômage partiel ont constitué un soutien
essentiel pour les salariés et les
indépendants
le gouvernement a par ailleurs annoncé
un vaste plan de soutien à
l'apprentissage afin que l'entrée dans
la vie professionnelle des jeunes
générations ne soit pas sacrifiée dans
cette optique le troisième budget
rectificatif pour 2020 prévoit une prime
exceptionnelle pour les entreprises qui
recruteront un apprenti du 1er juillet
2020 au 28 février 2020 tient cette aide
se monte à 8000 euros pour les majeurs
et 5000 euros pour les mineurs
monsieur le ministre notre action en
faveur de cette génération doit être
forte déterminée et innovante
l'un des axes de cette action est
intégration d'apprentis au sein de la
fonction publique et notamment auprès
des collectivités territoriales la loi
de transformation de la fonction
publique a prévu plusieurs mesures
favorisant l'apprentissage dans la
fonction publique
alignement des modalités de rénumération
des apprentis du secteur public sur
celles du secteur privé
mesures dans la fonction publique
hospitalière et encore participation du
centre national de la fonction publique
territoriale aux frais de formation des
apprentis
pour autant il est urgent de soutenir
plus encore le recrutement d'apprentis
dans la fonction publique et tout
particulièrement dans la fonction
territoriale
je le dis avec conviction les
collectivités sont vos alliés dans cette
stratégie en faveur de la génération qui
vient celle qui je le répète ne peut et
ne doit être une génération perdue
ma question est donc simple quelles
mesures concrètes comptez-vous mettre en
oeuvre pour soutenir l'apprentissage
dans la fonction publique
la parole est à monsieur olivier du soft
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics pour
deux minutes aussi merci à monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice vous
l'avais dit la loi de transformation la
fonction publique facilite le recours à
l'apprentissage dans la fonction
publique puisque nous sommes convaincus
que dans le public comme dans le privé
c'est une formation d'excellence
extrêmement professionnalisante et qui
permet de nombreux débouchés
nous avons fait en sorte d'ouvrir
l'apprentissage tout cas de le
développer pour les métiers du secteur
hospitalier
ce qui n'était pas le cas auparavant
nous avons fait en sorte aussi de
faciliter le recours à l'apprentissage
dans la fonction publique d'état et en
il y aura un effort particulier de
l'état puisque nous allons augmenter de
15% le nombre d'apprentis accueillis
dans les services de l'état pour arriver
à 13000 apprentis au total avec des
efforts significatifs fait sur les
ministères qui ont les filières
industrielles et plus
professionnalisantes
nous avons aussi prévu que
l'apprentissage soit une filière de
recrutement attractive en permettant
notamment pour les apprentis en
situation de handicap d un accès une
titularisation à titre dérogatoire au
corps et au cadre d'emplois la fonction
publique pour faciliter leur insertion
professionnelle
concernant la fonction publique
territoriale trois mesures peuvent être
soulignés à ce stade
la première vous l'avez évoqué c'est de
rappeler que la loi du 6 août à 2020 à
sécuriser le financement la formation
des apprentis et le cnfpt désormais
appeler a financé à 50 % des frais de
formation
pas plus tard que ce matin le conseil
d'administration du cnfpt a examiné la
convention de partenariat avec france
compétences et j'ai signé l'arrêté
permettant de sécuriser la
dissipation de france compétences au
financement de l'apprentissage
nous travaillons enfin un dispositif
exceptionnel qui consisterait comme dans
le secteur privé a accompagné les
employeurs publics territoriaux avec un
dispositif d aide au recrutement
notamment pour faire face à la période
de crise que nous connaissons les
échanges sont en cours pour fixer les
bonne mentalité
merci la parole et à monsieur philippe
bonnecarrère pour le groupe union
centriste
j'ai donc mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question va être complémentaire de celle
posée par monsieur eric de montgolfier à
partir de septembre nous allons à
l'évidence affronter une grave crise
économique et sociale
un plan de relance s'impose pour en
réduire l'impact est tâché d'en sortir
au plus vite
mais notre situation budgétaire ne nous
permet pas de le mettre en oeuvre seul
c'est à l'échelle de l'union comme tel
plan doit se déployer le plan de relance
mes chers collègues sera européen ou ne
sera pas c'est pourquoi le sommet
européen des 17 et 18 juillet
éventuellement un suivant consacré à ce
sujet va être déterminant les européens
et la france en particulier ont une
obligation de résultat l'exécutif a n'a
d'ailleurs bien conscience comme en
témoignent les déplacements du chef de
l'état aux pays-bas et bientôt en
allemagne
le plan de relance européen est un
projet de grande ampleur qui peut
impliquer d'aller plus loin dans
l'intégration mais il ne pourra pas
aboutir sans ressources supplémentaires
les deux solutions de financement les
plus prometteuses sont la taxe gars
femmes et la taxe carbone aux frontières
elles sont assises sur deux marqueurs de
notre temps la révolution numérique et
la crise environnementale la taxe gars
femmes s'imposent pour faire contribuer
les géants du numérique aux charges
collectives
la taxe carbone répond à l'urgence
écologique en rétablissant une équipe
économique entre les pays de l'union et
les pays extérieurs chine en tête
aussi madame la ministre quelles sont
les perspectives sur la taxe gars femmes
et sur la taxe carbone aux frontières
merci la parole émeutes à madame agnès
panière une hache et sur la terre d'état
auprès du ministre de l'économie et des
finances merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur bonne carrière
merci de mettre en lumière la
proposition historique de la commission
européenne pour la construction
européenne car 500 milliards d'euros de
levée de dette commune pour financer un
plan de relance de 500 milliards d'euros
c'est du jamais vu au niveau de la
construction européenne
et c'est un signal fort pour l'union
européenne et notre capacité à relever
ce défi
alors oui vous avez réseau nous fondons
beaucoup d'ambition pour le prochain
conseil européen et nous espérons qu'il
adoptera rapidement ce plan de relance
qui est nécessaire pour l'union
européenne et pas seulement pour
certains de ces pays mais pour la
solidarité économique de l'ensemble des
pays car nous faisons groupe nous
faisons masse en matière économique
s'agissant des deux taxes que vous
mentionnez ces deux taxes elles sont
plus que l'enjeu des financements
qu'elle pourrait apporter c'est
symboliquement la reprise en main de
notre souveraineté
le fait de faire payer l'accès à notre
marché unique et le fait de mettre en
place une concurrence loyale entre
l'ensemble des pays qui alimente la
production européenne
ou plutôt le marché européen c'est ça
dont il est question s'agissant du
mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières vous le savez madame van der
leyen s'est engagé à nous faire des
propositions pour la fin de l'année
s'agissant de la taxe sur les
plateformes numériques nous avançons au
niveau de l' ocde
nous avançons et je veux signaler que
les états unis sont toujours à la table
de négociation ce qui est intéressant à
noter par rapport à la communication qui
peut être fait par ailleurs et si nous
n'avons pas d'accord au niveau de l'
ocde
le commissaire breton a été parfaitement
clair
c'est au niveau de l'union européenne
que cette taxation se mettra en place
et je crois qu'avec ces deux éléments
nous envoyons un signal fort que nous
sommes à la fois une économie ouverte
mais que nous sommes sortis de l'ère de
la naïveté
merci monsieur bancaire vous avez 11
secondes si vous le souhaitez merci
madame josiane cost pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci monsieur le président monsieur
secrétaire d'état les chers collègues le
numérique apparaît comme un facteur de
notre résilience face à la crise
sanitaire
il a permis le maintien de
l'enseignement de l'activité économique
ou du lien social
mais cette expérience nous a aussi
rappelé l'ampleur des fractures sociales
territoriales et numérique
selon un récent rapport de l'insee un
français sur six cette année les prix
numérique
un sur cinq ne sait pas communiquer avec
internet
enfin sur trois manque de compétences de
base
80% de ceux qui n'utilisent pas internet
ont plus de 60 ans les personnes les
plus fragiles sont donc aussi celles qui
rencontrent le plus de difficultés à
accéder à cet outil indispensable
c'est d'ailleurs l'objet du travail de
notre collègue raymond vall dans le
cadre de la mission d'information sur
l'électro nisme du groupe rdse
il faut encore y ajouter les disparités
du déploiement du réseau sur le
territoire et le manque d'équipement des
familles les plus précaires les
difficultés liées à l'enseignement à
distance l'illustrent à un seul
ordinateur pour toute une famille un
réseau que l'on atteint dans un coin de
la maison ou au fond du jardin
impossibilité dans certains logements de
trouver le calme
ces situations sont parfois
insurmontables quand 5 à 10 % des élèves
ont été injoignable
des initiatives existent maison france
service plan très haut débit centres
sociaux connectés ou parce numérique
néanmoins les circonstances actuelles
conduisent à amplifier notre effort de
réduction de toutes ses factures alors
que les inégalités se multiplient si le
confinement accru l'intérêt pour le
télétravail cette perspective se solde
aussi par des attentes déçues dans de
nombreux territoires
la faiblesse du débit empêche trousses
l'installation de nouveaux habitants là
où justement il y en a le plus besoin
en vous envisagez vous monsieur le
secrétaire d'état d'accélérer la
politique de l'état en la matière je
vous remercie
merci monsieur cédric au secrétaire
d'état chargé du numérique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice josiane cost vous évoquez une
réalité particulièrement cruelle qui a
été celle du confinement qui préexistait
au confinement puisque c'est une réalité
que les élus sur le terrain les services
sur le terrain connaissent extrêmement
bien que cette réalité entre les gens
qui sont connectés et les gens qui ne le
sont pas et d'ailleurs c'est une réalité
qui va au delà du cas particulièrement
problématique des personnes âgées
puisque quand vous allez dans une
session de formation de pôle emploi
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le faire
vous avez énormément de jeunes qui sont
très forts pour aller sur les réseaux
sociaux mais qui ont énormément de mal
dès lors qu'il s'agit de s'actualiser
sur pôle emploi de faire un cv ou de
même de forwarder un email et cette
réalité elle a été particulièrement
cruelle pendant le confinement où nous
c'est des réalités et des libertés est
extrêmement basique qui ont été
inaccessibles pour nombre de nos
concitoyens qu'il s'agisse de
télécharger une attestation de sortie ou
même dans leurs relations sociales de
faire un appel ou une visioconférence
avec leurs proches ou leurs petits
enfants
creusant par là une fracture qui est une
facture économique est une facture
sociale qui est une fracture sociétale
et qu'ici on le dit très clairement
alimente une colère qui d'ailleurs a
affleuré au moment du grand débat où
quasiment dans chaque réunion physique
du grand débat les participants ont
évoqué le numérique comme un facteur est
un vecteur d'une forme d'exclusion alors
nous devons faire plus nous devons
travailler sur la connexion c'est ce que
nous faisons avec l espagne rien lâché
et je viens de normandie nous devons
accélérer sur l'équipement vous avez
cité l'exemple des familles avec un seul
ordinateur quand cinq enfants doivent
suivre l'éducation à distance c'est un
énorme problème et nous devons faire
particulièrement efforts sur les usages
puisque il ne suffit pas d'avoir la
connexion encore faut-il savoir se
servir d'internet pour axe
il ya un certain nombre de politiques
publiques qui ont été mises en place
depuis trois ans pour accélérer dans la
réduction de la fracture numérique
je pense que ce que nous dit le
confinement c'est qu'il faut accélérer
et que cette fracture qui préexistait
maintenant elle est béante et qu'il faut
qu'on s'en saisissent au bon niveau
notamment dans le cadre du plan de
relance c'est ce à quoi nous travaillons
actuellement
la parole est à madame christine bruneau
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen écologie merci monsieur le
président messieurs mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues en 2015 le
ministre macro prométhée la sauvegarde
de tous les emplois lors du rachat du
français alcatel par le finlandais nokia
cinq ans plus tard après déjà trois
plans de licenciements nokia perd 6 à
appliquer ce modèle de destructions
d'emplois avec la suppression de 1200 33
postes en france dont 400 sur le site de
lannion
dans mon département des côtes d'armor
les six ans des licenciements
impacterait le service de recherche et
développement qui travaille pourtant à
l'arrivée de la 5g et de la
cybersécurité
dois-je vous rappeler que ce groupe
touche actuellement entre 65 et 80
millions d'euros du crédit impôt
recherche qui financent 30% des 2500
salariés de ce même service
cette trahison des salariés ressenti
comme cela n'a pour seul objectif que
l'augmentation des rémunérations des
actionnaires et des hauts dirigeants du
groupe
tout cela sous le matelas bien
confortable des subventions publiques
dont le cas s'est gavé pouvons nous le
dira c'est tout simplement le sens des
éternels licenciements boursiers
les sites de lannion et de nos 16
également dans le sol dans l'essonne
participe pleinement à la réussite du
groupe avec des compétences
indispensables dans notre pays dans la
maîtrise de nos réseaux de
télécommunication votre simple demande à
nokia de revoir sa copie ne suffit pas
quand le gouvernement s'engagera-t-il
totalement en faveur de l'emploi de la
recherche de l'industrie en interdisant
les licenciements boursiers
comment vous pouvez vous sauvegardez une
souveraineté industrielle
je veux le faire la parole est à madame
agnès panière une hache et secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice pruneaux nokia a effectivement
annoncé un plan de réductions très
important de sa recherche et
développement en france
cette recherche et de développement et
n'est d'ailleurs pas uniquement orientée
vers la 5g mais elle couvre cet élément
là et c'est vrai que le retard pris peut
être un peu léger par la france sur
cette dimension est potentiellement un
des éléments auxquels nous devons être
particulièrement vigilants pour éviter
ce genre d' annonce et je veux confirmer
je serai très directe que nous avons
demandé à nokia de revoir l'ampleur de
ce plan est d'accompagner de minimiser
le nombre de départs volontaires mais
permettez moi de vous dire que ça fait
cinq ans que nous sommes aux côtés des
salariés pour les accompagner pour faire
en sorte que la france est l'un des
seuls pays voire le seul pays à avoir
été protégés contre des restructurations
dans cette entreprise
et ça c'est un fait autre fait également
nokia a permis de sauver alcatel qui
était malheureusement et c'était il ya
quelques années dans une situation bien
difficile vous le savez comme moi dans
une situation qui a conduit d'ailleurs à
faire ce rapprochement qui était
malheureusement la seule façon de sauver
des emplois en france
sauver cet acteur européen qui est
aujourd'hui confronté à une concurrence
très importante d'un autre acteur
européen ericsson que nous accueillons
et pour lequel nous allons essayer de
monter dans les prochaines semaines un
centre de r&d également donc ce il ya
aussi du positif dans ce secteur mais
également huawei qui est très accompagné
par son gouvernement
donc nous allons agir aux côtés des
salariés
sachez le nous sommes aujourd'hui à la
manoeuvre nous avons reçu hier les
organisations syndicales et nous
pousserons nokia juste dans leurs
retranchements pour obtenir les
meilleures garanties pour les salariés
pour notre recherche et pour notre
souveraineté
merci la parole est à monsieur jérôme
durain pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
monsieur le président chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
c'était en 2017 emmanuel macron avait
réussi à ringardiser les parties mon
parti le vôtre à celui de l'époque
monsieur le premier ministre en
brocardant leur incapacité à accepter ce
qu'ils venaient du camp d'en face
systématiquement aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron fait la même chose
regardons ce qui se passe sur un crime
déco side les sénatrices et sénateurs
socialistes ont proposé l'année dernière
un texte équilibré et applicables qui
visait à lutter contre l'impunité pour
les crimes les plus graves et à répondre
à une attente de la société
la réponse a été c'est une bonne idée
mais c'est non les députés socialistes
ont repris cette notion négocié avec une
version un peu différente on leur a dit
c'est non cette fois c'est la convention
citoyenne pour climat qui dit l'écocide
est utile dans une version plus
exigeantes
peut-être plus audacieuses qu'allez-vous
en faire monsieur le premier ministre il
ya peut-être un risque à ne pas écouter
les demandes qui remonte de la société
on peut parfois même sentir une forme de
mépris de frustration alors nous ne
sommes parlementaires d'opposition on y
est habitué mais attention à ce que la
société l-1 y prennent n'en prennent pas
ombrage
alors il ya l'écocide il y à l'iesf leur
établissement c'est non le référendum
sur la dpc non une commission d' enquête
sur une colline 19
c'est non c'est parce que pavlovien chez
le premier ministre vous allez écouter
la société à défaut d'écouter les
parlementaires
qu'allez vous faire de l'éco side
qu'allez-vous faire des conclusions de
la commission consultative des citoyens
la parole est à madame nicole belloubet
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
monsieur le président mesdames et
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur du rhin si
précisément cette convention citoyenne a
été mise en place à l'initiative du
président de la république c'est parce
que nous souhaitions nous souhaitons
écouter ce que les 150 citoyens tirés au
sort avait à nous dire sur le sujet qui
a été traitée nous souhaitions les
écouter et nous l'avons fait puisque
madame elisabeth borne a reçu cent
quarante neuf propositions qui ont été
étudiées et parmi celles ci vous le
dites vous le soulignez celle de
l'écocide les difficultés que j'avais eu
l'occasion de relever devant vous à
propos de cette notion d'éco side au
printemps 2010 9,1 en décembre dernier à
l'assemblée nationale ces difficultés la
demeure elles sont de deux ordres d'une
part on ne peut pas soumettre cette
proposition au référendum puisqu'elle
porte sur la législation pénale qui ne
fait pas partie du champ de l'article
rue du champ de l'article ça c'est d'un
point de vue procédural et au fond il y
a également une exigence dans notre
constitution je suis sûr que vous la
partagez
c'est l'exigence de précision de la loi
pénale or si je lis et vous avez vous
même dit que c'était peut-être une
écriture audacieuse si je lis ce qu'a
écrit la convention citoyenne elle parle
elle parle de la définition du crime
déco side dans des limites qui sont les
limites planétaires et elle évoque le
dépassement des limites planétaires
je ne suis pas tout à fait certaine que
cette notion-là correspondent à
l'exigence de précision de la loi pénale
qui figure dans notre constitution pour
autant pour autant monsieur le sénateur
la question qui est posée celle de
l'atteinte à l'environnement est une
vraie question est devant vous j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire avec ma collègue
et isabelle borne à propos du texte sur
le parquet européen texte dans lequel
nous avons institué des juridictions
pour l'environnement et une nouvelle
procédure la convention judiciaire pour
l'environnement
dans ce cadre là j'ai eu l'occasion de
dire que nous étions prêtes à réfléchir
à un délit plus générale de pollution
des eaux des sols de l'air qui pourrait
trouver place dans notre droit pénal de
l'environnement c'est donc sur
l'incitation de la convention judiciaire
d'un don de la convention citoyenne
pardon c'est sûr que nous pourrons
réfléchir ensemble à ces éléments là
nous croyons beaucoup évidemment à
toutes les propositions qu'il fonde de
lapin faut vraiment conclure madame la
ministre nous les soumettrons évidemment
parlement merci monsieur jérôme durand
il vous reste 32 secondes de répliques
la ministre je vous parle d'exigence
démocratique vous parler d'exigence de
précision de la loi pénale dominique
rousseau dans le monde d'hier dit pour
des confiner la france politiquement il
faut reconnaître la compétence des
citoyens emmanuel macron lui-même j'ai
mes sources dit j'ai besoin que vous
sachiez prendre des options forte même
radicale sinon il y aura le filtre de
ceux qui les mettront en musique
attention à ne pas trop filtré on peut
finir par faire déborder
la parole est à monsieur christian
cambon pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci veut merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères chers collègues depuis des
mois la turquie mène une politique de
puissance en méditerranée orientale et
multiplie les provocations alternant
démonstration de force et intervention
militaire
après les forages gaziers dans les eaux
territoriales chypriotes au mépris du
droit international
il ya eu l'offensive turque que contre
nos alliés de kurdes qui luttent
pourtant à nos côtés face à l'état
islamique puis le chantage aux flux
migratoires
les incursions en syrie en irak en libye
et j'en passe et voilà donc que la
turquie vient d'agresser maintenant la
frégate française courbet qui menait une
mission de surveillance de l'embargo des
armes au large de la libye pour le
compte de l'otan ciblée à trois reprises
par les radars de conduite de tir de
missile
türk notre bâtiment quelle humiliation a
dû se retirer pour éviter l' escalade de
la violence
voilà où nous en sommes arrivés voilà où
nous en sommes arrivés au sein même de
l'otan le secrétaire général stoltenberg
parlant sans rire de désaccord entre
alliés et nos protestations ne
recueillant que huit soutien européen
sur les trente membres ce grave incident
jettent une lumière crue sur la
faiblesse diplomatique et militaire
d'une europe décidément incapable de se
faire respecter et qui ne sert plus qu'à
financer les reconstructions de pays en
guerre ou à exposer la vie de ses
soldats pour jouer encore un rôle sur la
scène internationale mais cet incident
après bien d'autres signes hélas aussi
la perte d' influence de la france dans
une région de la méditerranée où elle
fut autrefois si respectée et si écoutez
nous en reparlerons ce soir lors du
débat du au proche orient
concernant le proche orient alors
monsieur le ministre ma question est
bien simple après les dénonciations et
les condamnations
la france et l'europe vont elles enfin
agir avec fermeté pour s'opposer à ce
nouvel impérialisme tueur en d'autres
termes allons nous passer de la
diplomatie des déclarations à la
diplomatie de l'action
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères pour
vous répondre
monsieur le président quand bon vous
étiez lundi soir à l'elysée lorsque le
président de la république recevait le
président sayed et vous avez pu entendre
les propos du président de la république
à l'égard de la turquie en disant en
particulier que la tire qui jouait un
rôle un jeu extrêmement dangereux et je
voudrais vous dire ici et dire au sénat
que la france estime indispensable que
l'union européenne ouvre très vite une
discussion de fond sans tabou sans
naïveté sur les perspectives de la
relation future de l'union européenne
avec ankara eco l'union européenne
défende fermement ses propres intérêts
car elle en a les moyens
vous avez à cet égard évoqué tout à
l'heure la sphère de la frégate courbet
là tout est absolument scandaleux réside
dans le fait que la frégate courbet
participé à un exercice de l'otan et que
la frégate turque il a interpellé elle
couvrait une violation de l'embargo sur
les armes décidé par les nations unies
c'est un acte grave que nous avons porté
au sein des instances de l'otan mais
plus largement il faut des
clarifications
il faut des clarifications sur le rôle
que la turquie entend jouer en libye où
j'estime que nous assistons une scierie
anisation de la libye puisque
l'intervention militaire delà de la
turquie se fait par le soutien de
supplétifs aux syriens
cela veut dire aussi que il faut
s'interroger sur la manière dont on va
pouvoir pousser la turquie à aller à la
négociation dit 5 + 5
parce que ce le fait que la turquie
renforçant sa son poids en libye abouti
au fait que les ruses renforce le leur
est donc une spécialisation croissante
ça veut dire aussi des explications sur
la méditerranée orientale sur le fait
que
il faut faire respecter le droit de la
mer le droit maritime internationale et
donc respecter les territoires de nos
propres alliés et des membres de l'union
européenne que son chypre et la grèce
cela veut dire aussi la même chose sur
les conclure je conclus au delà de la
compréhension que l'on peut avoir les
garder la présence de réfugiés en
turquie on ne peut pas accepter que les
réfugiés servent de moyen de pression et
d'instrumentalisation de la turquie à
notre égard donc ce débat doit denner si
merci de la question la parole est à
monsieur franck montaugé pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
monsieur le président cher collègue
madame la ministre du travail
votre réforme de l'assurance chômage a
été très dure à l'égard des français
pour lesquels le travail au delà du
besoin et de la nécessité est une valeur
centrale
le contexte économique et sociale
engendrée par la pandémie
laurent aujourd'hui inique et en réalité
complètement inadapté à la nécessité de
relance économique et à l'obligation de
solidarité nationale dans cette
situation comment entendez vous
concrètement revenir sur les principes
de votre réforme les mesures que vous
allez prendre doivent atténuer la crise
sociale et contribuer à la relance de la
demande intérieure du pays
le chômage va exploser pour tous ceux
qui seront confrontés retrouver un
emploi sera plus difficile qu'avant la
crise le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
français sera un facteur très important
de la relance de l'économie française
dans de nombreuses filières les chefs
d'entreprise compte sur la relance de la
demande intérieure pour restaurer leurs
citations d'entreprise l'économie marche
à la confiance
on le sait et un accompagnement
insuffisant de millions de chômeurs
empêchera en réalité le retour de cette
confiance indispensable prévoyez vous
madame la ministre de restaurer les
droits antérieurs à votre réforme est de
les améliorer
compte tenu de l'urgence économique et
social et a pris la parole est à madame
muriel pénicaud menace du travail
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur franck montaugé la crise
épidémie
qui se prolonge en crise économique et
sociale c'est pour ça que dans un
premier temps nous avons pris des
mesures immédiates dès le 14 avril par
un décret pour adapter la citation
l'assurance chômage au contexte du
confinement dans ce décret nous avons
permis le prolongement des droits
jusqu'au 31 mai ce avons prévu de
neutraliser la période de confinement
dans l'établissement et dans le calcul
des droits nous avons permis le cas de
démission légitime pour des salariés qui
auraient démissionné pour un autre
emploi qui se serait retrouvée juste
moment du confinement en incapacité de
prendre le nouvel emploi bref nous avons
pris toute une série de mesures pour
protéger immédiatement nos concitoyens
touchés de plein fouet par la situation
nouvelle inédite massive de confinement
vous m'interrogez sur la suite lorsque
nous avons fait la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui est
partiellement entre une application
pourquoi nous l'avons fait d'abord pour
tenir compte à la fois d'un impératif de
protection et aussi deux incitations à
l'emploi dans un contexte est vrai il
est vrai il ya quelques mois nous le
célébrions ensemble ou nous avions
réussi grâce à toutes les réformes que
nous faisons à faire descendre le
chômage de près de 10% à 8,1 pour cent
et nous étions sur la voie d'aller vers
les 7 % le contexte
effectivement à changer mais nous avons
voulu aussi lutter contre l'extra
l'excès des contrats courts
beaucoup des parties de cette réforme
visait à amener plus de cdi et moins de
contrat extrêmement court nous avons
aussi protéger les indépendants qui
maintenant une assurance chômage nous
avons mis en place des droits nouveaux
pour les démissionnaires qui voulait
créer leur entreprise
je ne crois pas que vous voulez
supprimer tout ça la question qui se
pose aujourd'hui c'est comment avec
pragmatisme devons nous adapter un
certain nombre de joueuses par les
principes qui sont bons sur le long
terme mais un certain nombre de curseur
à la situation nouvelle
effectivement de crise de crise
économique et donc de risque sur
l'emploi dans le cadre de la
concertation
sociaux que je mène sous l'égide à la
demande du président de la république et
douloureuse président de la république
les reçoit tous tout à l'heure nous
avons un sujet principal c'est la
mobilisation pour l'emploi ya cinq
sujets un des sujets il faut bien sûr
nous en discutons mais ça se passe par
le dialogue social et avec pragmatisme
monsieur franck montaugé vous avez
quarante et une secondes de répliques
merci madame la ministre vous ne m'avez
pas convaincu mais vous n'avez surtout
pas du tout parlé de formation
professionnelle et je le regrette parce
que c'est un point clé dans mon groupe
nous pensons que cette période difficile
doit être mise à profit pour former aux
métiers de demain que nécessite dans la
plupart des filières la transition de
modèles jusqu'à la sortie de crise on
pourrait imaginer que l'état finance en
quasi totalité les stages de fin
d'études et de pré embauche des jeunes
pour tous les niveaux de qualification
nécessaire
dans la même idée l'état pourrait aussi
accompagner les chômeurs en phase de
formation dans les filières nouvelles ou
en reconversion et on sait qu'il y en a
beaucoup qui sont concernés et je
rajoute à cela
n'oubliez pas non plus madame les
contrats très court dans l'hôtellerie
l'événementiel le tourisme qui font
aussi l'économie une part de l'économie
et de la vitalité de mercy non la parole
est à monsieur jean bizet pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le secrétaire d'état aux
transports et à trait aux trans manche
je voudrais y associer mon collègue
michel vaspart qui suit ces sujets avec
beaucoup d'intérêt cette activité
maritime est en situation difficile
difficile à cause de l'épidémie qu'ovide
19 difficile avec un break site dur qui
s'annonce difficile également au regard
des distorsions de concurrence avec les
pavillons étrangers qui perdure la
question est simple
quelles sont les mesures elles
d'accompagnement envisagées par le
gouvernement dans le transport maritime
transmanche
dans l'hypothèse d'un rattachement du
transport transmanche au secteur du
tourisme
peut-on considérer que le prêt garanti
par l'état soit basée sur les trois
meilleurs mois de chiffre d'affaires de
l'entreprise qu'une exonération de
charges patronales soit au moins assuré
le temps du remboursement par les trans
par les entreprises de ce prêt
c'est-à-dire au moins cinq ans enfin
peut-on envisager un plan de
communication à l'adresse de la
communauté et de la clientèle
britannique indispensable à la veille du
vrai qu site je rappelle qu'au cours de
l'année 2019
l'espagne a déjà consacré plus 10
millions d'euros merci par l'état
monsieur jean baptiste djebbari
secrétaire d'état chargé des transports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bizet merci pour vos questions
qui me permet de revenir à la fois sur
le déconfinement du secteur maritime et
la reprise des liaisons transmanche
comme vous savez les faits les navettes
maritimes ont continué leurs activités à
un niveau réduit pendant le confinement
environ 50% de l'offre pour 10% de la
fréquentation et je profite de
l'occasion pour remercier les acteurs
qui ont poursuivi ces liaisons et qui
ont notamment joué un rôle essentiel
dans le cadre de la poursuite du fret
maritime
vous l'avez dit le trafic reprend
progressivement le gouvernement est
évidemment conscient des difficultés
rencontrées par les opérateurs
raison pour laquelle nous avons agi à
trois niveaux d'abord l'ensemble des
acteurs du transmanche ont tous
bénéficié des mesures de droit commun
proposé aux entreprises françaises
ensuite grâce à l'action aux échanges
que j'ai pu avoir avec mes homologues
britanniques et irlandais nous avons pu
mettre en place un dispositif qui permet
de compenser à la fois une partie des
charges de personnel et les charges
variables au bénéfice de ces opérateurs
et enfin deux tranches mans je vous
l'avais évoqué est intégré au plan
tourisme et pourra bénéficier de mesures
telles que le maintien de l'activité
partielle à 100 % jusqu'en septembre
prochain
vous l'avez aussi évoqué d'autres
mesures sont demandés par les acteurs du
secteur nous sommes en train de les
expertiser il s'agit notamment de
l'extension saisonnière des prêts
garantis par l'état de l'exonération
d'un certain nombre de cotisations
patronales et salariales d'ailleurs ou
encore de du plan de promotion que vous
avez cités qui seraient portés par atout
france et enfin le transmanche
bénéficiera directement des mesures de
la stratégie maritime qui est en cours
de finale de finalisation il serait mais
trop présente et nous viserons notamment
à maintenir la compétitivité et l'emploi
européen des amateurs sachez monsieur
sénateurs que nous sommes pleinement
mobilisés et en plein soutien de ces
opérateurs de ces liaisons essentiel à
nos territoires
monsieur bizet vous avez 43 secondes
possible de répliques sur terre d'état
je prends acte de votre réponse mais à
mon avis elles ne sont pas à la hauteur
des enjeux
j'aurais souhaité vous voir intégrer
véritablement les lignes directrices
proposées par la commission européenne
dès janvier 2004 qui permet dans le
transport maritime comme dans le
transport aérien qui sont des jets
dirait des filières extrêmement je
dirais perturbé par des concurrence
souvent déloyale d'exonérer précisément
ces entreprises de charge ceux de
charges sociales patronale les
britanniques l'ont fait les danois l'ont
fait la france ne l'a toujours pas fait
c'est là le problème
si nous voulons rien du str et alizée
les entreprises il faudrait davantage
compétitif les crises sont des
amplificateurs de je dirais deux
tendances et des révélateur de
fragilités la fragilité de la france là
tu elle est très attentive aux merci la
parole est à monsieur alain cazabonne
pour le groupe union centriste
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame un ministre
la transition écologique et solidaire
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
rendu ses conclusions qui n'ont rien de
révolutionnaire en matière énergétique
alors que l'allemagne a dévoilé ses
ambitions de devenir leader mondial de
l'hydrogène vert comme l'a rappelé mon
collègue montgolfier en mettant 9
milliards d'euros et que le danemark va
développer des normes un parc
d'éoliennes offshore pour la fabrication
de cet hydrogène
ces pays ont raison car à condition
d'être produit avec de l'électricité
issue des énergies renouvelables
l'hydrogène est le carburant du futur un
carburant décarbonés exploitables en
quantité illimitée et stockables madame
la ministre
la france ne peut pas rater le coche de
l'hydrogène
d'autant moins que tout est prêt pour
l'accueillir des véhicules existe des
trains alstom à l'allemagne l'an
prochain en angleterre des bus des
voitures
j'ai ici une de ses voitures du futur du
présent cheveux qu'on doit dire et
j'espère que si une décision devait être
prise par rapport à la limitation des
vitesses vu la motivation six voitures
ont une grosse phase i pour continuer la
roule à 130 des initiatives
industrielles se font jour un peu
partout à pau avec phébus à belfort où
se tiendra un salon de l'hydrogène en
décembre en vendée où une entreprise
nantaise va produire de l'hydrogène dès
ou encore chez moi en aquitaine où j'ai
proposé à plusieurs entreprises que les
usines ford de blanquefort sera converti
en sites de production d'hydrogène
mais ces initiatives nous prospérons
passant international miser sur le tout
batterie
ce n'est pas miser sur l'avenir les
batteries ne sont ni une colonie durable
madame la ministre ne pas passer à côté
de la vraie révolution énergétique
d'autres temps
comment la france va t-elle se convertir
à l'hydrogène
la parole est à madame elisabeth bornes
ministre de la transition écologique et
solidaire
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur cazabonne
alors je vous le confirme l'hydrogène
décarbonés et incontournables pour
réussir la transition vers une économie
bas carbone
c'est notamment à levier clé pour la
mobilité décarbonée pour la
décarbonation de la production de
chaleur des process industriels ou
encore pour l'intégration massive des
renouvelables dans notre mix énergétique
c'est pourquoi depuis le début du
quinquennat ce gouvernement est très
mobilisé sur le sujet nous nous sommes
un des premiers pays à avoir présenté
une stratégie globale un plan hydrogène
dès 2018 en 2019
nous avons soutenu 90 millions d'euros
nous avons emporté 90 millions d'euros
pour soutenir de nombreux projets
territoriaux qui sont très prometteurs
et qui démontre l'engouement
l'engouement pour cette filière dans
notre pays
en 2020 la filière continuer à monter en
puissance
nous avons lancé un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt au début de
l'année qui a connu un très grand succès
près de 160 projets dossiers ont été
déposés qui représentent 32 milliards +
32 milliards d'investissements et donc
l'enjeu majeur aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment de créer des véritables
écosystèmes industriels autour de
l'hydrogène et c'est pourquoi nous
présenterons dans les prochaine semaines
notre stratégie hydrogène qui visera à
renforcer le caractère industriel de
l'offre française également à mutuelle
visé l'offre et la demande à l'échelle
des territoires pour créer des véritable
hub hydrogène multi du multi usages pour
des premières réalisations de grande
ampleur donc je vous le confirme sur le
sénateur nous sommes très mobilisés sur
ce vecteur énergétique qui a toute sa
place dans notre politique énergétique
je remercie monsieur cazabonne
j'avais huit secondes pour une courte
réplique et je vous donne acte je
rappellerai simplement j'ai revu l'autre
jour la déclaration de john kennedy
lorsqu'il a lancé le programme apollo
alors que les russes était donné
largement gagnant on a vu comment un
pays portées par une ambition avec un
objectif était capable d'atteindre cet
objectif
la parole est à monsieur jean marc boyer
pour le groupe l'est républicain la
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
150 citoyens 149 propositions retenues
dimanche dernier pour une convention
citoyenne pour le climat pour nous dire
comment se loger se nourrir se déplacer
consommez travailler et produire neuf
mois de travail en milieu fermé de 150
citoyens tirés au sort
triés sur le volet vert pas forcément
vertueux sans être élu
comment comment serait-il légitime pour
parler au nom de 66 millions d'habitants
leur avis pour être pris en compte par
les décideurs politiques mais ils n'ont
nullement la légitimité des lunes la
nation pour prendre des décisions au nom
du peuple qui a pour représentant nos
élus municipaux départementaux régionaux
parlementaires députés et six sénateurs
le président de la république a confirmé
hier je cite le plan de relance ne peut
pas passer par les régions et des
départements
si l'on respecte le calendrier électoral
c'est une drôle de conception de la
démocratie comme si elle était devenue
un obstacle à l'efficacité au contraire
en période de crise la démocratie est
encore plus une ressource des
propositions sont irréalistes et
déconnectés du terrain
monsieur le premier ministre avec la
proposition de cette convention de
limiter la vitesse à 110 km/heure sur
les autoroutes
êtes vous prêts à renouveler
l'expérience malheureuse du 80 km/heure
et pensez vous que la réduction du temps
de travail à 28 heures payées 35
relancera l'économie
attention aux interdictions et aux
contraintes supplémentaires que dénoncer
déjà nos gaulois réfractaires dans nos
territoires
attention à la promotion idéologique de
fausses vérités en supprimant les vols
intérieurs pour des prétextes
environnementaux non suffisamment
justifié
l'empreinte carbone aériennes et de 4 7%
vous nous emmener vers une décroissance
mortifère de nos territoires en les
déconnectant des mobilités et de
l'accessibilité merci monsieur monsieur
le premier ministre vous le savez ces
propositions sur liberticide ne sont pas
l'émanation de la volonté du peuple a il
faut la cacher vous qu'elles vont sauver
la france et sauver la planète
madame elisabeth bornes ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire pour
vous répondre
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur boyer écoutez vous
voyez moi je pense que quand 150
citoyens tirés au sort
à l'image de notre pays prennent sur
leur temps personnel pour travailler
avec beaucoup de détermination
pendant neuf mois avec beaucoup de
sérieux
cela mérite le respect cela mérite le
respect alors qu'est ce que nous disent
ces citoyens ils nous disent
et je précise qu au départ ces citoyens
vous savez certains étaient climato
sceptiques ils nous l'ont dit qu'est ce
qu'ils nous disent ils nous disent que
des premiers week-ends ils ont pu
échanger avec des experts avec des
scientifiques et qu'ils ont pris une
claque qu'ils ont pris une claque en
réalisant l'ampleur du défi climatique
et sur cette base on joue qu'au film
qu'ils ont travaillé en auditionnant des
industriels en auditionnant des élus en
auditionnant sans doute des
parlementaires et sur la base de tout ce
travail ils nous ont remis effectivement
ils nous ont remis une vision globale de
nombreuses propositions et je pense que
vraiment le respect impose de ne pas
sortir de mettre en exergue quelques
mesures alors que le principe du travail
qui a été réalisé par ses citoyens
c'est vraiment d'apporter des réponses
globales sur la rénovation des bâtiments
sur la styliste artificialisation des
sols sur le développement de la mobilité
propre sur le renforcement du fret
ferroviaire et je pense que sur tous ces
sujets il ya un large consensus sur
l'intérêt d'aller dans ce sens du reste
nous avons une occasion de débattre de
projets de lois qui portent ces mêmes
orientations
alors effectivement je pense que c'est
important que le débat se poursuivre
les consensus qui ont été trouvé entre
les citoyens ils doivent continuer à se
construire dans la société
que ce soit à l'occasion d'un débat
parlementaire ou d'un référendum
donc on est bien d'accord monsieur le
sénateur il faut que le débat se
poursuivre notamment ici même au sénat
la parole est à monsieur yves où colas
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture et
de l'alimentation
durant les deux mois et demie de
confinement alors qu'une grande partie
de l'économie s'est retrouvée par la
paralyser le secteur agricole et
agroalimentaire est resté au front pour
garantir à nos concitoyens la continuité
de l'approvisionnement alimentaire de
qualité et diversifiée chacun d'entre
nous a pu mesurer sur son territoire et
vous l'avez souvent rappelé monsieur le
ministre ici même dans cet hémicycle
en effet malgré les mesures de barrières
à mettre en place la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre dans certaines filières
les difficultés de transport des
produits la nécessité de réorienter une
partie des débouchés les agriculteurs
n'ont jamais cessé de travailler et de
produire comme toujours malgré les aléas
ils ont su faire preuve de résilience et
faire face cela mérite
monsieur le ministre d'être souligné et
salué ses agriculteurs ce ne sont pas
seulement des exploitants sont aussi des
salariés des salariés permanents ou
saisonniers selon la mutualité sociale
agricole l'agriculture mobilise chaque
année 600 mille travailleurs saisonniers
dont 22,6 pour cent sont étrangers la
fermeture des frontières et la crise a
mis en lumière les difficultés des
saisonniers français mais aussi
européennes et nord africaines je
souhaite en particulier attirer votre
attention sur la question de leur
logement faute de structures adaptées
logent dans des habitations précaires et
insalubres
aussi je vous demande monsieur le
ministre ce qu'entend de faire le
gouvernement pour soutenir ses salariés
et pour améliorer leurs conditions et
leur accueil en particulier de leur
logement
je vous remercie parole à monsieur
didier guillaume ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur yvon collin
c'est un véritable hymne d'amour à
l'agriculture que vous avez évoqué vous
avez raison de saluer les a vécus
et les salariés parce que grâce à eux
grâce aux transformateurs grâce au
distributeur
la chaîne alimentaire a tenu et nous
avons pu continuer nous alimenter et
c'est une belle chose et merci pour le
soutien que vous leur avez témoignés
mais il y à un sujet qui nous tient
particulièrement à coeur au niveau
gouvernement je suis très heureux que
vous ayez poser cette cette question
c'est celui du salariat agricole
le salarié agricole c'est plus de 700
mille personnes par an c'est pendant la
période actuelle
cent mille travailleurs saisonniers
supplémentaires étrangers qui doivent
venir en france pour faire tenir notre
modèle agricole et ce n'est pas rien et
bien souvent ces salariés ont des
évidemment des contrats précaires et
sont logés de façon très compliqué
depuis la crise du coc vide
la commission interministérielle a mis
en place en termes de gestion arrière de
guides pratiques qui sont très
importants mais nous savons très bien
dans le domaine agricole
comme dans tout un tas d'autres domaines
dans le domaine de la restauration par
exemple que ces salariés là ont du mal à
trouver un logement
donc on du mal à venir et notamment dans
nos entreprises agroalimentaires qui
sont performantes et 13 très nombreuses
notamment membre en bretagne on a du mal
à les héberger c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement a travaillé
avec action logement
nous avons parlé avec le premier
ministre avec julien de normandie avec
action logement ont pris 2,2 mesure tout
d'abord une aide exceptionnelle de 150
euros pour une durée de quatre mois
pendant toute la crise pour aider à
l'hébergement des deux salariés
agricoles français ou étrangers
évidemment et puis nous avons aussi
essayé de faire en sorte d'amener une
autre aide pour tous les salariés
agricoles qui sont en difficulté
également 250 euros c'est quelque chose
de très important vont lui mettre en
place si nous arrivons à aider les
salariés à se loger
alors nous pouvons aller de l'avant et
enfin nous travaillons sur de nouvelles
mesures pour la suite notamment pour la
rénovation énergétique de leur propre
logement
nous devons garder des salaires
messieurs ligne merci monsieur yvon cola
il vous reste 16 secondes de répliques
si vous le souhaitez nos simplement
remercier monsieur le ministre de sa
réponse est
dire que nous serons vigilants sur
l'application bien madame annie
guillemot pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la culture
les marchands de journaux font partie de
notre quotidien notre culture en
garantissant l'accès à près de 2000 titi
sont des vecteurs essentiels de la
culture et de l'information et des
acteurs essentiels de la proximité
plus précisément à travers les 23 1000
points de vente répartis sur l'ensemble
du territoire il assure un véritable
service public en garantissant la
diffusion et la pluralité d'une presse
indispensable à notre vie démocratique
mais après les 55 jours de confinement
qui ont mis à rude épreuve des
commerçants revenu généralement modestes
ils doivent désormais faire face à la
crise du secteur de la distribution de
la presse
en effet l'entreprise presstalis qui
distribuait 75% de la presse écrite sur
l'ensemble du territoire national est en
faillite dans la métropole de lyon et le
rhône la filiale régionale de presstalis
a été placée en liquidation judiciaire
depuis le 15 mai ainsi depuis plus de
cinq semaines les marchands de presse ne
peuvent plus vendre à leurs clients
nombre de journaux habituels notamment
les nationaux qui ne reçoivent plus dans
le même temps les loyers de ces
commerces ont cours
cette situation pénalise très lourdement
les 550 pièces de la métropole de lyon à
la situation économique déjà souvent
fragiles et génère une baisse du chiffre
d'affaires de l'ordre de 75% risque de
précipiter la fermeture de nombre de
maisons de presse mais c'est le cas
aussi à marseille à toulon c'est le cas
aussi à nantes et dans de nombreuses
autres villes sans mauvais jeu de mots
car la situation ne s'y prête pas le
temps presse ces professionnels sont aux
abois
car si l'an dernier 579 points de vente
ont fermé fin avril 740 ont déjà tiré le
rideau
il faut donc éviter que la situation
d'ores et déjà extrêmement préoccupante
pour le pluralisme de la presse ne vire
à l'hécatombe
aussi monsieur le ministre que
comptez-vous faire rapidement pour
qu'une solution pérenne soit enfin
trouvée à cette crise de la distribution
de la presse
la parole est à monsieur franck riester
ministre de la culture
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice guillemot comme vous
savez le gouvernement est très attaché à
suivre de très près l'avenir des
marchands de presse
il représente un maillage très important
culturel et un maillage très important
d'information partout dans les
territoires
le gouvernement a pris la décision
d'assouplir dans la réforme louis michel
les conditions de gestion de ces
machines presse pour leur donner des
meilleures conditions économiques
il a veillé à ce que à travers la crise
de presstalis il puisse toucher tous les
bus qui leur était promis le
gouvernement veille aussi à ce que
malgré les difficultés de presstalis que
vous avez rappelé malgré le redressement
de presstalis au niveau du siège et de
bobigny de la liquidation des dépôts de
presse
l'avenir de la distribution de presse
soient garanties pour que notamment les
marchands de journaux puisse continuer
de vivre c'est la raison pour laquelle
le gouvernement soutient la reprise de
presstalis au haut niveau aux parisiens
et aux niveaux de bobigny par la
coopérative des quotidiens en
investissant 80 millions d'euros pour
accompagner cette reprise et c'est la
raison pour laquelle ils travaillent
avec les populaires les dépositaires
indépendant avec les messageries
lyonnaises de presse avec les préfets de
région pour trouver des solutions dans
les 15 dépôts qui doivent être repris
suite à la liquidation de presstalis
en ce qui concerne lyon une solution a
été trouvée un plan de secours est
d'ores et déjà en oeuvre en ce qui
concerne toulon et marseille dans les
tout prochains jours des solution
devrait être trouvée l'avenir la
distribution de la presse est essentiel
aux yeux du gouvernement
c'est une garantie d'assurer le
pluralisme de la presse et la bonne
qualité de l'information de nos
compatriotes
le gouvernement investit depuis des
années des années beaucoup d'argent pour
garantir cette distribution
nous allons continuer de le faire
notamment pour les petits éditeurs de
presse et pour les marchands de journaux
particulièrement touchée par les
perturbations presstalis sur la zone de
lyon et sur la zone de marseille
la parole est à nouveau à vous madame
annie guillemot pour 20 secondes si vous
voulez rester monsieur le président oui
monsieur le ministre la situation est à
lyon pas résolu puisque nous n'avons
toujours pas les nationaux libération le
monde et que ses patrons de presse
ces maisons de presse elles perdent
aussi des clients et c'est vraiment un
drame humain ils ont joué le jeu
pendant confinement ils ont ouvert et
ils ont répandu justement à des livres
et des journaux
je crois vraiment que c'est un drame
économique pour les salariés de
presstalis d'ailleurs qu'ils vont être
au chômage mais c'est aussi un drame
humain pour tous ces patrons des maisons
de presse qui ne comprennent pas
pourquoi on ne va pas plus vite merci la
parole est à madame céline boulay sp
rogner sur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le ministre les chiffres le
montrent la délinquance n'a cessé de
croître ces dernières années l'année
2020 a mal commencé
l'aggravation est inquiétante et le défi
lié au confinement est déjà derrière
nous il existe un phénomène alarmant qui
n'est pas nouveau mais en pleine
expansion auquel nous n'avaient apporté
à ce jour aucune réponse
les jeunes étrangers mineurs ou qui
prétendent l'être et qui multiplie les
cambriolages les vols avec violences et
agressions en tout genre ils sont saouls
ils ont souvent entre 10 et 17 ans quand
ils sont mineurs ce qui n'est pas
toujours facile à déterminer si le
phénomène est très présent à paris il se
répand désormais dans les grandes
métropoles françaises
a bordeaux il ya quelques semaines on a
découvert un réseau de recel en bande
organisée par des adultes qui
instrumentalisent s est jeune ces
délinquants mineurs isolés étrangers
parfois sans domicile fixe empoisonnent
la vie des habitants
j'ai pu le constater très récemment dans
mon arrondissement où j'ai de nombreux
témoignages
il ne s'agit pas de faits marginaux or
ces voyous savent qu'un simple rappel à
la loi est souvent le solde de tout
compte de leurs délits et ils
recommencent à l'envi il se rit de la
france désespérant pour les forces de
l'ordre c'est aussi injuste qu'un
compréhensible pour les victimes
or la réponse pénale n'est pas adaptée à
la situation
le positionnement de madame la garde des
sceaux qui souhaite instaurer une
justice je cite restaurative pour je
cite encore faire dialoguer victimes et
auteurs d'infractions ne rassure
personne si ce n'est les délinquants
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous nous
confirmer que ces jeunes
instrumentalisés par des réseaux
d'adultes qu'avez vous fait depuis le
déconfinement pour lutter contre ce
phénomène
comment comptez vous restaurer
l'autorité de l'état sur cette question
je vous remercie
la parole à madame nicole belloubet
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice vous laisse péronier vous
poser une question dont je connais la
sensibilité
j'ai eu l'occasion d'en parler souvent
avec des maires qui sont venus me voir
notamment ceux qui sont au bout des
lignes de rer et qui connaissent parfois
des intrusions violentes et fréquente
dans certains commerces et donc ses
dialogues là se sont traduits par un
certain nombre de mesures qui figurent
dans le code de justice pénale des
mineurs qui a été publié le 13 septembre
dernier le gouvernement a une politique
générale pour les mineurs qui est porté
par adrien taquet et dans cette
politique générale le code de justice
pénale des mineurs n'est qu'un des
éléments qui répond évidemment aux
mineurs délinquants au sein de ce code
de justice pénale des mineurs dont j'ai
eu l'occasion de dire que nous en des
batteries ion parlement parce que c'est
tout à fait important au sein de ce code
de justice pénale des mineurs figurent
des éléments qui s'adresse
spécifiquement aux mineurs isolés dont
vous parlez en effet nous avons fondé la
réécriture de cette ordonnance de 45 sur
les principes fondateurs de l'ordonnancé
de 45 une justice spécialisée la
primauté de l'éducatif mais aussi une
procédure qui est adapté aux exigences
de notre moment et dans cette procédure
la nous savons qu'un certain nombre de
mineurs isolés pas tous parce qu'il ne
faut pas tous considéré que ce sont des
délinquants mais nous savons qu'un
certain nombre de ces mineurs isolés
refuse par exemple de donner leur
identité et donc sont difficilement
appréhendable par la justice nous avons
décidé dans le code de justice pénale
des mineurs que ceux qui refuseraient de
c
et aux procédures qui permettent
d'établir leurs identités ils seraient
assimilés à des récidivistes
ce qui concrètement concrètement nous
permettrait de les déférer au parquet
ils seraient alors jugées dans une
audience unique entre un et trois mois
suivant le déferrement et cela je crois
nous permettra d'apporter une réponse
rapide c'est l'objet général de ce code
de justice pénale des mineurs et une
réponse efficace
vous avez cité madame la sénatrice la
justice restaurative permettez moi de
dire que cette procédure la de justice
restaurative n'est pas une peine
c'est un complément qui peut être mise
en oeuvre dans un certain nombre de cas
pour les mineures comme pour les adultes
ça n'a rien à voir avec les sanctions
qui sont décernées qui sont pires madame
à l'égard des mineurs récidivistes
nous cherchons les équilibres entre la
fermeté et l'éducation
je vous rappelle que les prochaines
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
auront lieu mercredi 1er juillet 2000 va
à 15 heures je vais suspendre la science
elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour l'examen
de la proposition de résolution en
application de l'article 34 1 de la
constitution visant à en encourager le
développement de l'assurance récolte la
séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement que vous
avez pu suivre en intégralité et en
direct sur public sénat une séance de
questions d'actualité où l'on sent
l'effet du déconfinement une forme de
retour à la normale quinze questions et
pas seulement des questions consacré aux
qu'ovide et à ses conséquences
de nombreux sujets locaux plus variés
ont été abordés de la justice des
mineurs à la situation en turquie y est
alors on retient notamment plusieurs
questions sur la convention citoyenne
pour le climat avec deux questions de
jérôme bignon pour les indépendants mais
aussi jérôme durain qui a lui notamment
interrogé le gouvernement sur
l'inscription du crime déco side dans la
loi une proposition qui a déjà été porté
dans les deux chambres par les
parlementaires socialistes qui se sont
vu opposer une fin de non-recevoir par
la représentation nationale
mais voilà que cette proposition revient
donc à travers cette convention
citoyenne
d'évidence le gouvernement n'y est guère
favorable pour des raisons juridiques
nous a expliqué la garde des sceaux
nicole belloubet l'opposition serait
plus profondes
ce que nous explique le canard enchaîné
aujourd'hui autre sujet majeur largement
lors dé la relance la crise le chômage à
propos de chômage d'assurance-chômage
une réforme pour l'instant suspendus
pour l'instant mise entre parenthèses
écouter et bien la réponse de la
ministre du travail tout à l'heure
muriel pénicaud
lorsque nous avons fait la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui est
partiellement entre en application
pourquoi nous l'avons fait d'abord pour
te dire qu'on a la foi de l'impératif de
protection et aussi deux incitations à
l'emploi dans un contexte est vrai il
est vrai il ya quelques mois nous le
célébrions ensemble ou nous avions
réussi grâce à toutes les réformes que
nous faisons a fait redescendre le
chômage de près de 10% à 8 1% et nous
étions sur la voie d'aller vers les 7 %
le contexte
effectivement à changer mais nous avons
voulu aussi lutter contre l'extra les
excès des contrats courts
beaucoup des parties de cette réforme
visait à amener plus de cdi et moins de
contrat extrêmement court nous avons
aussi protéger les indépendants qui
maintenant une assurance chômage nous
avons
mis en place des droits nouveaux pour
les démissionnaires que voulait créer
leur entreprise
je ne crois pas que vous voulez
supprimer tout ça la question qui se
pose aujourd'hui c'est comment avec
pragmatisme devons nous adapter un
certain nombre de choses par les
principes qui sont bons sur le long
terme mais à certains de curseur à la
situation nouvelle
effectivement de crise de crise
économique et donc de risque sur
l'emploi dans le cadre de la
concertation
les partenaires sociaux que je mène sous
l'égide à la demande du président de la
république et douloureuse président de
la république les reçoit tous tout à
l'heure nous avons un sujet principal
c'est la mobilisation pour l'emploi il
ya cinq sujets à des sujets nous en
discutons mais ça ça se passe par le
dialogue social et avec pragmatisme et
weedon muriel pénicaud cas donc
largement éludé la question de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage à ladite
tout ce qui avait été fait en matière
sociale pendant le confinement mais n'a
pas expliqué l'avenir de cette réforme
qu'elle renvoie au dialogue avec les
partenaires sociaux place tout de suite
aux réactions salle des conférences
steve vous êtes donc celle des
conférences et vous êtes avec le
président du groupe et l'air ici au
sénat bruno retailleau oui bruno
retailleau
bonjour vous avez rencontré donc
emmanuel macron ya première réunion avec
les présents le président du groupe du
sénat
vous avez envie de dire quoi enfin le
président de la république rencontre les
présidents de groupes di siena bonne
chose je veux rappeler que ce n'est pas
de son initiative c'est à l'initiative
du président du sénat gérard larcher qui
lui avaient demandé qu'il rend compte
les présidents de groupe au sénat et on
a toujours intérêt dans la période que
traverse la france a discuté pour le
reste j'ai trouvé quelqu'un qui est très
très loin de se réinventer
s'il ya des françaises ou des français
qui pensent qu'ils mêlent macron va se
réinventer je préfère leur dire que il
est sûr de lui
sûr de sa valeur sûre de son
intelligence et que je ne le vois pas
changer dit se réinventer bon maintenant
je lui ai soumis les propositions que
nous avons travaillé dans le cas du
groupe et j'étais en revanche absolument
stupéfait de la conception qui la
décentralisation ce qu'on a bien vu
qu'un des problèmes pendant toute la
période du corps navires us où on avait
une bureaucratie d'état qui étaient
incapables de commander des masques
incapable de faire des dépistages massif
x et les collectivités qui se sont
portées en avant pour assumer des
responsabilités que l'état aurait dû
assumer que l'état n'a pas
fumer mais lui c'est pas ça du tout la
conception qui la décentralisation c'est
la conception d'un grand commis de
l'état et nous a même dit d'ailleurs que
s'il devait y avoir un plan de relance
financés par l'état pas qui passerait
par les régions et les départements
jamais une donnerait d'argent aux
départements et régions si il n'y avait
pas une concession si on ne repoussait
pas le calendrier électoral
donc pour lui en fait y'a pas de
compatibilité entre la démocratie et
l'efficacité c'est donc la négation de
la démocratie et c'est profondément
inquiétant bruno retailleau autre sujet
la sphère alexis colère mediapart a
révélé une lettre écrite par emmanuel
macron au parc national financiers et
tenant à couvrir alexis colère qui était
soupçonné vous savez de conflit
d'intérêts votre réaction
écoutez est-ce qu'il ya encore des
compatriotes qui pensent qu'il n'ya pas
d'ingérence entre la justice et la
sphère du pouvoir qui peut penser
aujourd'hui en france qui a une parfaite
indépendance de la justice
on a vu dans la sphère fillon le chef du
parquet national financier dénoncé une
ambiance avec d'énormes pressions avec
des instructions de madame champrenault
sa supérieure hiérarchique qui peut
penser un seul instant que cette affaire
a été traitée dans la sérénité
normalement qui peut penser que la
démocratie n'a pas été faussé et la
nouvelle ingérence président de la
république dans un dossier qui touche
quelqu'un qui lui est très très proches
je pense que la démocratie française va
mal il n'ya pas de séparation des
pouvoirs entre l'assemblée le législatif
et l'exécutif l'assemblée étant souvent
la remorque pour ce qui concerne sa
majorité avec l'exécutif heureusement il
ya le sénat quand même qui assure cette
indépendance
mais il ya aussi un problème entre
l'exécutif et la justice et c'est
préoccupant
et dans cet appartement qu'est-ce que
vous demander la réouverture du dossier
une nouvelle enquête de la police
peut-être moi je donne pas de leçons
mais quand je voudrais expliquer à vos
spectateurs que quand emmanuel macron
dans cette histoire qui
a conduit françois fillon à perdre dès
le premier tour l'élection
présidentielle je constate qu'il a voulu
saisir le csm
le conseil supérieur des juristes la
magistrature je veux simplement dire que
sur en 3 en 2015 2018 sur les 1000 48
plaintes adressées à ce csn simplement
deux ont été jugés recevables pour 0
sanctions dont qui peut penser que
demain le csm aura une décision ou
prononcera une sanction personnes merci
beaucoup bruno retailleau d'avoir
répondu à mes questions je précise qu'à
l'instant les juges d'instruction
annonce la reprise des investigations
donc dans la sphère colère c'est à vous
tam
oui merci beaucoup steve et puis autre
réaction à votre micro tout de suite et
bien le président du groupe uc ici au
sénat le président du groupe centriste
hervé à marseille
oui oui je suis avec le président hervé
marseille le monsieur marseille bonjour
même question qu'à bruno retailleau tout
à l'heure comment s'est passée votre
rencontre avec emmanuel macron il ya
façon classique est tout à fait sereine
le président qui était accompagné de son
secrétaire général monsieur colère son
conseiller monsieur grangeon a reçu les
présidents de groupes du sénat qui se
sont exprimés les uns après les autres
pour faire connaître leurs
préoccupations
et puis il a répondu à la fin
globalement avant d'aller s'occuper de
l'europe
peut-être vous évoquez alexis colère sur
cette affaire sur ces révélations de
mediapart quelle est votre réaction à ce
que vous parlez comme bruno retailleau
d'une entorse peut-être à la séparation
des pouvoirs
écoutez je connais pas ce dossier je
sais pas ce qu'il ya dedans moi j'ai
toujours pensé qu'il fallait pas mêler
le politique et le judiciaire
on l'a vu récemment encore avec les
rebondissements dans ce qu'on a pu
appeler la sphère fillon on le voit
aujourd'hui avec cela faire colère je
pense que la politique ça se passe
devant les électeurs en responsabilité
et tous ceux qui essaie
d'instrumentaliser la justice que ce
soit avec les uns ou avec les autres et
bien donne une bien piètre image et il
faut pas s'étonner ensuite j'allais dire
de voir les extrêmes en profiter vous
parlez de la sphère fiant vous évoquez
la sphère fillon le jugement sera rendu
lundi à ce que les juges doivent prendre
en compte les déclarations de l'ex chef
du parquet national financière écoutez
c'est troublant il ya une commission
denquête qui travaillent à l'assemblée
nationale il lui appartient d'aller au
fond des choses
quand madame ou led qui était au coeur
de la sphère révèle
ce qu'elle a révélé effectivement c'est
préoccupant et ça mérite qu'on aille au
fond de la faire quand on sait quelles
ont été les conséquences de cette
affaire sur la vie politique française
donc la moindre des choses envers le
dossier c'est en tous les cas quand on
écoute et qu'on entende parce que le
président a saisi le conseil supérieur
de la magistrature il faut savoir
qu'entre 2015 et 2018 est à peu près
1500 plaintes qui ont été déposées
auprès du csm
il ya 2 % de suivi d'effets alors si on
veut enterrer un dossier ont saisi le
csm petite dernière question on a vu que
la statue de colbert à l'assemblée
nationale avaient été dégradées avec
cette inscription négrophobie d'état ça
vous choque
oui c'est choquant je crois que que
toutes ces affaires où on touche à
l'histoire de france a la mémoire qui
est celle de l'aco la france avec sa
part d'ombré avec sa part
resplendissante ne mérite pas autant
d'infamie si on commence à revisiter
l'histoire à l'aune des valeurs de notre
époque on va pas en sortir
je pense qu'il ya des choses beaucoup
plus importantes on va avoir des
mouvements sociaux très difficile à la
rentrée ça c'est important l'emploi des
françaises et des français notamment des
jeunes
on a toujours une affaire concernant les
retraites qui est pendante
on va avoir des élections
départementales et régionales dont on ne
sait pas si elles vont être maintenu à
la date fixée d'après le président ça
pourrait bien être retardé donc tous ces
sujets là sont importants et c'est
autrement plus importants que toucher au
symbole de notre histoire à travers tel
ou tel statut
merci beaucoup à hervé à marseille
d'avoir répondu à mes questions c'est à
vous tous merci beaucoup
steve pour ses réactions salle des
conférences on reste avec vous pendant
la demi-heure mais pour l'instant et
bien c'est le débrief de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
avec trois invités sur ce plateau
j'ai eu le plaisir d'accueillir
françoise gatel bonjour je sénatrice us
et d'ille-et-vilaine également avec nous
et bien j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
jérôme bascher bon
bon sénateur et l'air de l'oise et enfin
sur ce plateau bernard jomier bonjour
vous êtes sénateur écologiste sénateurs
un rattaché au groupe ps ici au sénat et
sénateur de paris on va commencer par
parler de ce sujet qui n'a pas été
évoquée lors des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
mais c est bien la sphère colère et la
sphère fillon alors concernant la sphère
colère on va rappeler les faits depuis
juin 2018 l'actuel secrétaire général de
l'elysée proche parmi les proches des
manuels macron alexis collard est visé
par une enquête du parquet national
financiers pour une affaire de conflit
d'intérêts entre ses anciens postes dans
la haute fonction publique et ses liens
familiaux avec l'armateur msc l' affaire
a été classée sans suite en août 2019 et
mediapart a publié hier une note d'
emmanuel macron note datée et bien d'un
mois plus tôt de juillet 2019 dans
laquelle le président de la république
explique alexis kohler l'avait tenu
informé de ses liens avec msc et avait
demandé à être dessaisi de ses dossiers
tout cela est remplie bien de suspicion
sur et bien les intrusions du politique
au sein du judiciaire jérôme bascher
votre réaction
la première réaction ce qu'il est normal
que nous n'ayons pas eu des questions
d'actualité sur ce sujet car on ne peut
pas dire qu'on veut la séparation des
pouvoirs et que le parlement demande des
comptes à la justice au gouvernement il
y aurait quelque chose mais des
questions et hier sur la sphère fillon à
l'assemblée nationale
chacun chacun a ses habitudes ou des
sommes et baudroie taille on vient de le
rappeler pour la séparation des pouvoirs
on après dire que mediapart a raison que
les juges ont tort non c'est un peu plus
compliqué que cela dans l'ensemble du
dossier
moi j'ai confiance dans la justice de
mon pays mais il n'est de justice que
d'hommes et les hommes ils n'ont pas
tous âges à dire la volonté parfois les
femmes qui font la justice les
procureurs dont il s'agit pour la faire
fillon par exemple ils n'ont pas tous
jédir les volontés du général de gaulle
de dire non et de se dresser de se
camper de faire front comme il disait
bernard jomier est-ce que vous jugez
mais qu'il y a eu là une intervention du
politique dans une procédure judiciaire
individus
ce qui est interdit par le principe de
la séparation des pouvoirs
il semblerait que le chef de l'état a
reconnu cette intervention donc c'est
l'elysée a affirmé que oui ce cette
intervention existait donc moi ce que je
note c'est que au moment de la sphère
benalla on a vu un grand désordre
institutionnel au sommet de l'état on a
vu jusqu'où le chef de l'état pouvait
aller pour défendre un de ses
collaborateurs jusqu'à refuser
l'évidence enfin il a fallu que une
contrainte énorme pour qui enfin
alexandre reynal à soient écartés du
coeur de l'état bon visiblement c'est un
peu la même histoire qui se rejoue c'est
à dire qu'il défend son secrétaire
général
alors on peut estimer que c'est très
estimable défendre ses collaborateurs
mais ça témoigne quand même d'un
désordre institutionnel dans la
conception du coeur de l'état et ça ça
n'est pas sain en démocratie
françoise gatel un désordre
institutionnel dans la conception de
l'état chez emmanuel macron est ce que
vous êtes d'accord et est ce que il y a
eu et bien là un problème d'indépendance
de la justice par rapport au pouvoir
politique car je précise que dans un
premier temps le parquet national
financier avait publié un rapport
accablant puis un autre disculpant sur
ce conflit d'intérêts du secrétaire
général de l'elysée c'est ce que
rapporte mediapart
alors moi je pense que il faut savoir
raison et principes garder le principe
le plus fort dans notre démocratie c'est
la séparation des pouvoirs et
l'indépendance de la justice
ensuite mediapart
allard c'est sans doute sa fonction de
révéler des choses
présentés d'une manière qui nous
interroge sur la démocratie certains
diraient un peu croustillantes et qui
nous amène son king mais si je n'ai pas
dit le contraire
je dis juste que ça nous amène à
réfléchir et c'est très bien
je pense que moi je connais pas les
dossiers juste une chose ce que j'ai cru
comprendre de la faire c'est que je ne
justifie rien j'essaie juste de
comprendre les facteurs ainsi que le
président de la république a fait une
attestation 10
qu'à l'époque où il était en quelque
sorte l'employeur de monsieur colère ils
attestent de voilà aux rhétiques d'une
sphère ne pas le faire moi je pense
qu'il vaut mieux éviter les choses mais
il ne faut pas non plus qu'on s'emballe
à chaque fois qu'il ya des révélations
que médiapart a sans doute raison de le
faire et il en est de même sur la sphère
fillon où je pense que sur la sphère
fignon il ya une vraie interrogation sur
cette sollicitation de l'exécutif pour
avoir des informations et en même temps
il ya les faits sur cette affaire dont
ne mélangeons pas tout et surtout
faisons très attention à ne pas créer
dans l'opinion publique
un sentiment de tous compromis jédir
c'est très grave il faut dire les choses
il faut enquêter mais soyons factuel et
soyons tous responsables est ce que pour
vous il ya des comparaisons possibles
avec la sphère fillon rappelons que et
bien l'ex chef du parquet national
financier a évoqué des pressions mais
des pressions de sa hiérarchie
elle ne parle pas de pression politique
est-ce que c'est différent pour vous
faire voilà je dis moi je veux bien
qu'on soit naïve jusqu'à un certain
point je pense que s'il ya eu des
pressions de la part de la hiérarchie
sans doute que la hiérarchie t
extrêmement curieuse de savoir mais on
peut imaginer qu'un exécutif compte tenu
de l'importance de la personne en qui
était jeudi en question compte tenu du
contexte électoral moi je ne suis pas
choqué qu à un moment l'exécutif veuille
veuille être informé est-ce que c'est
scandaleux est ce que sais je
enfin je veux dire il faut aussi qu'on
soit très vigilant c'est une chose
d'être informés c'est une chose de faire
pression et c'est une chose d'interférer
dans les affaires
jérôme bascher emmanuel macron a demandé
au conseil supérieur de la magistrature
de vérifier l'indépendance de l'enquète
dans le cadre de la sphère fillon vous
en rêvez c'est formidable formidable
marseille vient de le dire formidable ça
me donnera rien et puis quand bien même
cela donnerait quelque chose pour dire
'est-ce qu'on allait un peu plus vite ou
un peu moins vie
it est ce qu'il ya une pression du garde
des sceaux qui a déjà été rappelées
condamné par la cour de justice de la
république
à ce moment là comme son souvenir c'est
pas très intéressant on verra ce que dit
le juge à la fin vous voyez qui le que
françois fillon soit blanchi par la
justice
on aurait alors là quelque chose de
compliqué s'il est coupable que la
procédure soit allé un peu plus vite un
peu moins vignes pour moi ce n'est pas
très important
l'important c'est que la justice soit
rendue à condition qu'elles le fassent
dans les conditions habituelles et pas
sous pression
à tout le moins la cheffe de la
procureure de du pns pardon dont je
tairai le nom n'a pas fait preuve de
de liberté vis-à-vis quand même d'une
magistrate compétentes reconnues sinon
il n'aurait pas été nommé à ce poste et
une dernière réaction sur cette affaire
bernard jomier et alors que et bien
effectivement il exulte il demande
solennellement à la ministre de la
justice de saisir le parquet pour
l'ouverture d'une information judiciaire
contre x ou d'une enquête préliminaire
pour forfaiture
on s'en est bien à la droite qui juge
que là où il ya un traquenard politico
judiciaire qui a été mise en place et
qui commence vraiment à à aborder ce
sujet on sent la volonté de surenchère
politique
voilà sa tendance à 30 personnes après
françois fillon a droit comme tout le
monde à une procédure judiciaire
équitable si elle a été inéquitable et
ben ça devra être établi et vous faudra
en tirer les conséquences
jusqu'à preuve du contraire elle n'a pas
été inéquitable la procédure est en
train d'arriver à son terme en quelque
sorte même bien que elle puisse se
poursuivre encore quelques années
voilà je crois qu'il faut il faut en
rester là et je ne je trouve que ce jeu
qui consiste à discréditer sans cesse
les institutions judiciaires qui sont
une autorité dans notre république
d'ailleurs qui ne sont pas un pouvoir et
ça c'était la volonté des fondateurs de
la vème république
je le rappelle au passage que ce ne soit
plus un pouvoir judiciaire une autorité
judiciaire donc une volonté un peu de
minoration des juges
et bien moi je trouve que les
discréditer sans cesse et dans le même
temps porter dans le débat public tous
les jours la nécessité d'avoir une
police et une justice efficace c'est
juste un peu contradictoire attention à
ne pas abîmer nos institutions
tout de suite on va continuer le débat
mais on va salle des conférences
rejoindre steve jourdain vous êtes avec
le sénateur communiste des
hauts-de-seine pierrot tu y as pour
réagir à l'actualité
oui pierre vaux une liasse bonjour la
staging colbert devant l'assemblée
nationale a été dégradée avec cette
inscription 1 négrophobie d'état quelle
est votre réaction
moi je suis historien donc je vais faire
je vais vous faire une observation
d'historiens alors là vous êtes dans la
salle des conférences au sénat là vous
avez
un certain nombre de fresques
historiques là par exemple il ya clovis
dont clovis il faut l'effacer c'est
quelqu'un qui a cassé le vase de
soissons ça se fait pas c'est pas bien
bon genre j'en plaisante un peu mais je
je pense que l'histoire ce n'est pas un
tribunal
l'histoire c'est ce qui permet de
comprendre de mettre en parallèle des
processus de les identifier
si on commence aujourd'hui à juger tous
les personnages de notre histoire
d'abord on n'y arrivera pas et je pense
que c'est pas que ces vins c'est pas
c'est pas intéressant donc ce que je ce
que je préférerais mois plutôt que de de
s'en prendre comme ça à des à des
statuts c'est que on lance un vrai
travail de réflexion sur qu'est-ce qui a
été la traite la traite des noirs
pendant une bonne partie de notre
histoire
comment napoléon 1er dont vous avez le
trône ici à réinstaurer l'esclave âge
dans les antilles alors que l' esclavage
avait été avait été supprimée donc là il
ya des vraies questions d'histoire et je
pense qu'il faudrait j'aurais travaillé
là dessus ça serait plus intéressant que
de que de s'en prendre aux statuts si je
comprends bien vous condamner cet acte
et vous comprenez en même temps que la
mémoire d'un colbert ministre de louis
xiv donc initiateur du code noir qui
légifère sur l'esclavagé dans les
colonies puisse susciter des réactions
chez certains de nos compatriotes mais
c'est toute l'histoire qui doit susciter
des réactions
je pense qu'on doit s'interroger en
permanence sur notre histoire
sur quelle est notre histoire de quoi
elle se elle se constitue notre histoire
coloniale doit être repensée absolument
repenser je pense que notre âme en
notamment notre histoire coloniale en
afrique du nord et en algérie doit être
un sujet d'intérêt d'études et
aujourd'hui il faut consacrer beaucoup
de moyens pour comprendre ce que
la france a fait la barre ça c'est je
pense que ça c'est essentiel
à la question comment on des patios
justement là ce débat c'est par un
traitement historique des données
historiques dont distancié où on essaye
de mettre en parallèle de constituer
l'effet de les mettre en parallèle et de
l'est et de les comprendre
si on aborde notre passé historique avec
un souci de juger avec nos conceptions
actuelles on n'y arrivera pas et c'est
pas très intéressante vous êtes
historien vous savez comme une
différence entre histoire et mémoire la
statue d'un colbert sais c'est aussi un
signe mémorielle qu'est ce qu'on fait
dans ces cas là les mais l'âme la
mémoire moi je l'entretiens autrement
mais différemment par exemple je suis
tous les ans au moins deux mois rial du
mont valérien pour célébrer la mémoire
des résistants qui ont été fusillés et
je porte une un regard particulier sur
ce qu'ils ont fait et ce pour quoi ils
ont été fouillés fusillés et j'essaye de
défendre les idées pour lesquelles ils
ont été fusillés pour moi là il ya un
acte de mémoire qui est fort et qui est
intéressant parce qu'il est constructif
et positif
merci beaucoup monsieur le sénateur
d'avoir répondu à mes questions c'est à
vous tam en plateau oui merci beaucoup
aux estives on va parler de ce sujet
cette statue de colbert vandalisé devant
l'assemblée nationale avec ce tacle
cette inscription négrophobie d'état
françoise gatel qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
on entend à l'instant car aux usa ce qui
nous dit l'histoire n'est pas un
tribunal
oui et ceux qui aujourd'hui juge les
choses mais qui sont ils
quelle est la vérité moi je suis
profondément bouleversé par sa maîtresse
sincèrement parce que il s'agit pas de
justifier des périodes de notre histoire
qui ont sans doute été des périodes
qu'on aurait souhaité autre mais
l'histoire des hommes
elle est ainsi faite et que l'histoire
année là
il n'y a pas enfin en tout cas
l'histoire elle est faite d'épisodes
d'épisodes de vie certains qui sont plus
positifs plus souriants et d'autres
voilà qu'on n'aime pas et qu'on regrette
mais en même temps je pense qu on a
aujourd'hui un regard sur l'histoire à
l'aune de ce que nous sommes des vérités
que l'on peut penser être des vérités
alors que ce sont plutôt parfois soit
des phobies choix défend talent et qu'il
faut savoir poser les choses et que je
pense que garder dans l'espace public
une statue de colbert ça n'est pas à
rendre hommage à l'esclavagisme mais
qu'on doit expliquer les choses
reconnaît mais moi j'ai très peur de ces
gens qui aujourd'hui s'érigent en juges
et en prophète de de la vérité ce qui se
passe c'est extrêmement grave et
extrêmement inquiétant est ce que vous
partagez cette inquiétude
bernard jomier il ya à la fois ces actes
extrêmes avec ces tags avec ses statuts
qui sont déboulonnés il ya aussi ceux
qui disent eh bien la place de ses
statuts elle est dans des musées avec
des cartels explicatifs et pas forcément
ainsi au milieu de l'espace public avec
le sentiment est bien qu'on leur rend
hommage c'est ce que dénonce certains à
travers ses statuts moi j'aime pas ces
actes de violence ces valets tagué en
rouge saccagé une statue ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'on ne peut pas déboulonné
des statuts des peuples l'ont fait les
statues de staline ont été abattus à la
chute de l'union soviétique du
communisme à paris nous avons des
baptisés des rues dont débaptiser les
rues alexis carrel
voilà c'est un eugénisme donc on a des
bâtis des rues donc ce n'est pas exclu
mais ce que je remarque c'est que il ya
un trouble sur notre identité commune et
qui c'est qui s'exprime depuis des
années ce travail autant d'identités je
pense qu'on devait travailler plus à
tisser ce que va être dans le futur
l'identité commune de notre pays
ce sera bien plus productif que de
s'égarer sans cesse à retourner sur le
passé ça c'est le travail des historiens
ç'a très bien été dit le travail des
politiques c'est de trouver comment
cesser cette fragmentation de notre
société qui
à l'oeuvre qui est extrêmement
destructrice pour notre république et de
retrouver l'identité commune de notre
pays de tisser cette identité commune on
a un vrai travail de rave odeur de notre
société à faire et évidemment c'est pas
en aspergeant des statuts ça n'est qu'un
symptôme mais il faut l'analyser au fond
alors jérôme bascher comment réconcilier
notre société c'est là la question que
vous posez bernard jomier puisque
effectivement tout cela intervient aussi
et bien à la suite du mouvement mondial
sur rogers du floyd la suite des
manifestations sur adama traoré ne peut
pas nier ces clivages qui lie à
extrêmement important ces manifestations
qu'il ya aussi eu en france dernièrement
oui mais bon moi j'aurais bien
effectivement qu'on se rassemble sur ce
qui fait notre histoire commune plutôt
qu'on essaye de trouver des boucs
émissaires des boucs émissaires du passé
des boucs émissaires du présent et qui
ne fait aucune construction
je n'ai pas compris qu en déboulonnant
quiconque
on n'est jamais construit un pays mois
les dernières statues des boulettes des
dangers mémoire liban c'est celle de
l'état islamique qui ont détruit des
parties de l'histoire et des histoires
de ces endroits en france la dernière
fois qu'on a déboulonné des statuts
c'était sous l'occupation je ne suis pas
sûr que ce soit des périodes tout à fait
glorieuse de chacun de ces endroits de
ces pays pour essayer de faire mémoire
il faut effectivement ce qu'on a appris
nous à l'école c'est effectivement que
colbert le fondement d'économie de
colbert a été fondée oui sur la traite
des noirs comme ça a été dit oui c'était
vrai et c'était une des façons à
l'époque de faire arriver à dévorer
coliques parce qu'on n'avait pas les
mêmes idées pages d'opinion sont
totalement scandaleuse évidemment mais
il faut bien comprendre ce qu'on
valorise à tel ou tel moment est aussi
reconnaître que tout n'est pas glorieux
dans le passé moi j'avais envie de vous
dire une chose qui va être évidemment un
peu scandaleuse moi je crois que le
général de gaulle et à tuer des
allemands pendant la guerre 14 est ce
que on va déboulonner général de gaulle
pour vous de passer avec plaisir mais
non mais ce n'était pas vraiment
comparable mais oui mais il y a
quand vous commencez à faire n'importe
quoi chacun est le premier ministre la
semaine dernière l'a dit avec brio il
l'a dit il a dit là chaque français
chaque personne chaque mot l'histoire à
sa période glorieuse et sa période
sombre
même gérard larcher neft même gérard
larcher un mot encore pour juste
conclure sur ce sur ce sujet françoise
gatel j'ai sur le fait que ce soit quand
même aussi le symptôme d'un problème
actuel le fait qu'on se mette à
déboulonner enfin qu'il y ait ces
problèmes de lag
ça reflète un problème actuel au gré
allaoua je ne sais pas si c'est soulève
un problème actuel en tout cas c'est un
symptôme de quelque chose mais nous nous
ne nous trompons pas sur la maladie la
maladie n'est pas celle qui est
diagnostiquée par ceux qui s'empare de
deux de ses statuts pour les déboulonner
qui nous laisse croire une chose qui
n'est pas vrai moi je crois aujourd'hui
dans cet emballement d'une société qui
est une société qui alors on n'a pas
arrêté de le dire mais là c'est vrai
pour de vrai c'est à dire elle est
fissurée et qu' on est aux communautés
et moi j'étais frappé quand gérard
collomb est partie souvenez-vous du
ministère de l'intérieur
il a dit une phrase qui m'a glacé
aujourd'hui nous vivons côte à côte
demain nous serons face à face et ceux
qui s'expriment aujourd'hui c'est la
vérité de chacun
sans doute parce que notre société n'a
peut-être pas su intégrer suffisamment
les uns et les autres nous avons des
efforts à faire et en même temps ne
soyons pas dupes de ceux qui
instrumentalisent des peurs de ceux qui
instrumentalisent le communautaire juste
alors pour déboulonner quoi les valeurs
de notre société notre république faut
aussi qu'on le dise tranquillement
paisiblement
allez on passe à un autre sujet qui est
largement marqué cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement ce
sujet bien c'est celui de la relance
économique après et bien la pandémie
decaux vide
cette relance économique a été abordé à
travers notamment un échange entre le
rapporteur général
budget ici au sénat albéric de
montgolfier et la secrétaire d'état
d'espagne rne h et on les écoute et on
en reparle juste après pourrais vous
parler du prochain plfr qui constitue
c'est vrai une déception puisqu'il ne
comporte aucune mesure de relance
aucune mesure de relance alors que notre
pays connaît une chute de son pib de
plus de 11%
et si on se compare notamment à
l'allemagne l'allemagne décidé des
mesures de relance vous l'avez vu à plus
de 50 milliards d'euros dont 9 milliards
pour l'hydrogène ce qui représente un
investissement de plus de 5,5 pour cent
du pib
nous en sommes à 2 5% en france si nous
attendons comme peut-être le grand dans
le prévoit le plf
le budget pour 2021 cela risque d'être
trop tard nous aurons en quelque sorte
perdu six mois six mois par lequel nous
connaîtrons des défaillances
d'entreprises ma question est donc très
simple
pourquoi attendre pourquoi attendre pour
adopter des mesures de relance
indispensable vous avez raison cette
crise allait inédite on prévoit une
baisse de notre produit intérieur brut
de 11 %
et comme vous le savez très rapidement
et vous le salut est d'ailleurs des
mesures d'urgence ont été prises quatre
mesures d'urgence qui ont permis de
venir au secours de notre économie très
rapidement car l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est
de stabiliser notre économie et c'est ce
que nous faisons nous le stabilisons
avec 14 milliards d'euros de financement
n'est pas tout à fait l'épaisseur du
trait ce plan sera prolongée par un plan
de relance vous l'avez dit ce plan de
relance nous y travaillons il visera à
accompagner la transformation de notre
économie
cette transformation nous en avons déjà
les éléments nous avons déjà des crédits
d'ailleurs disponible le sur
amortissement fiscal c'est un élément de
transformation
rassurez vous nous ne manquons pas
aujourd'hui de carburant pour avancer
mais pour faire ce plan de relance il
faut stabiliser l'économie
avoir une vision sur l'économie mondiale
et nous serons au rendez vous dès
septembre voilà pour cet échange tout à
l'heure lors des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement les efforts du
gouvernement dans la relance sont ils
suffisants jérôme bascher bah oui parce
que ce qu'il en était à -11% et
aujourd'hui le fmi annonce moins douze
ennemis donc on voit bien que plus ça va
plus le gouvernement que dans ça va pas
ça ne va pas
certes on a dit on a eu le plan de
soutien le plus généreux mais en vérité
on a plutôt inciter des gens à rester
chez eux et à ce que l'économie ne
repartent pas donc là on a un effet
pervers d'un soutien fort
c'est après aussi des raisons sanitaires
qui ont ils passé à 81 4%
les mesures de chômage partiel c'est
effectivement les mesures les plus
généreux d'europe et donc pour certains
c'est un outil très bien mais pour
d'autres ça a empêché où ça ne va pas
inciter à reprendre le travail
donc on est en retard là dessus mais la
deuxième chose qui est celle que dit
albéric de montgolfier des mesures de
relance par exemple sur le thermique et
bien ça il faudra attendre le budget
prochain tous les gens qui sont prêts
aujourd'hui à rénover leur maison mais
ils attendent ils attendent le plf et
que font les entreprises du bâtiment on
avait un débat hier le savez au sénat là
dessus elles attendent tout le monde
attend on est dans l'attentisme
et c'est ça qui creuse la reprise de la
croissance bernard genier votre votre
réaction à ce que les efforts du
gouvernement sont à la hauteur paille du
chômage partiel le chômage partiel a
aussi pu éviter du moins dans un premier
temps et bien des licenciements massifs
c'était aussi ça le sens est bien de
cette mesure prise par le gouvernement
oui c'était trop tôt pour avoir un
jugement définitif mais très clairement
l'enjeu on le connaît on doit retrouver
une activité économique meilleure y
compris parce que c'est les plus
précaires qui souffrent de cette
activité économique altéré que les
conséquences elles sont sociales et
elles sont graves de la crise sanitaire
mais on est en même temps face à un
choix extrêmement structurants talent et
s conques relance économique comme avant
ce qu'on a fait en 2008
ou est-ce que à cette occasion là on
revisite nos modes de production et
effectivement on va vers une transition
écologique réelle on lance un grand plan
de rénovation des bâtiments économie et
emplois non délocalisables plus écologie
est ce qu'on met effectivement la
priorité sur les mobilités non polluante
et cetera et cetera
et là le gouvernement paraît hésiter et
il faut sortir de cette hésitation est
très volontaire c'est l'heure de la
transition écologique
l'occasion la relance économique
françoise gatel à ce qu'il faut profiter
et bien de ce moment de crise pour
changer de modèle c'est ce que nous dit
bernard jomier alors que l'on sent bien
et bien que il ya aussi l'urgence en ce
moment pour beaucoup de français et paye
on le voit de plus en plus de plans
sociaux de suppressions d'emplois en
france
il faut conjuguer il faut conjuguer les
deux mois je souligne le l'effort que
l'état a fait un effort extrêmement
coûteux pour globalement nos finaux avec
le chômage à temps partiel qui a permis
de maintenir les entreprises pendant la
crise et qui a permis aussi d'éviter des
licenciements extrêmement brutaux
aujourd'hui on voit bien que ces
événements vont arriver je crois que
surtout il faut un plan de relanc fort
mais il faut surtout un plan de relance
rapide
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce que
disent mes collègues comme sans triche
sans doute faire la synthèse c'est à
dire je pense qu'il faut tout de suite
donné du travail aux gens ça veut dire
du travail qu'on sait faire
parce que pour cuillé roland il faut pas
qu'on ait besoin de former des gens donc
ça veut dire que les plans de rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments les artisans
les grosses entreprises s'affairent il
faut foncer dans tout ça parce que c'est
aussi du développement durable et c'est
de l'économie de demain et qu'en même
temps il faut partir sur des champs un
peu nouveau et audacieux et j je
voudrais bien moins quelque chose quand
même qui m'étonne c'est à dire que on
nous dit qu'il faut aller très très vite
son plan de relance et je partage et
j'ai cru comprendre qu'ils hier le
président de la république a dit aux
présidents de groupe que parce qu' il
fallait aller très vite et très fort on
pouvait reporter les élections
départementales et régionales
non et en même temps je pense que il y à
là enfin il ya là une contradiction
c'est une tradition que la lentille sa
vision les collectivités absolument dons
parce que effectivement faut aller vite
il faut aller fort parce que les
conséquences dramatiques qu'il faut
surtout pas reporter d élections au plus
je pense que la démocratie doit quand
même rester prépondérante qu'on a cette
fois les vitres fois l'effort il faut
faire des choses que l'on peut faire
donc faut pas révolutionner et inventer
des plans de relance sur des thématiques
trop nouvelle mais il faut voilà glisser
doucement fortement et volontairement
vers une économie de demain il faut
réarmer l'industrie en france
l'industrie en france il faut dire qu'il
ya urgence c'est ce que l'on voit
notamment et bien avec les plus pression
d'emploi échanges tout à l'heure et bien
sûr nokia nok ray qui suppriment des
emplois
écoutez cet échange entre la sénatrice
communiste christine bruneau est
toujours secrétaire d'état en espagne
est relâché en 2015 ministre macro
prométhée la sauvegarde de tous les
emplois lors du rachat du français
alcatel par le finlandais nokia
cinq ans plus tard après déjà trois
plans de licenciements nokia perd 6
appliquer son modèle de destructions
d'emplois avec la suppression de 1200 33
postes en france dont 400 sur le site de
lannion
dans mon département des côtes d'armor
votre simple demande à nokia de revoir
sa copie ne suffit pas quand le
gouvernement s'engagera-t-il totalement
en faveur de l'emploi de la recherche et
de l'industrie en interdisant les
licenciements boursiers
comment vous pouvez vous sauvegardez une
souveraineté industrielle
nokia a effectivement annoncé un plan de
réductions très important de sa
recherche et développement en france
cette recherche et développement et
n'est d'ailleurs pas uniquement orientée
vers la 5g mais elle couvre cet élément
là et c'est vrai que le retard pris peut
être un peu léger par la france sur
cette dimension est potentiellement un
des éléments auxquels nous devons être
particulièrement vigilants pour éviter
ce genre d'annoncés donc nous allons
agir
des salariés et le nous sommes
aujourd'hui à la manoeuvre nous avons
reçu hier les organisations syndicales
et nous pousserons nokia juste dans
leurs retranchements pour obtenir les
meilleures garanties pour les salariés
pour notre recherche et pour notre
souveraineté elle était trop court
jérôme bascher le risque tout de même
est dangereux dans cette séquence c est
bien que certaines entreprises prennent
aussi un peu le prétexte de ce qu'on
vide pour faire des licenciements des
licenciements prévus
déjà alors qu'ils sont dans une bonne
santé économique c'est ce que l'on voit
avec nokia c'est ce qu'on va avec nokia
c'est ce qu'on a vu aussi dans l'aérien
joue lequel je crois qu'il ya déjà eus
avant la crise sur les quais vides des
plans de licenciement dans l'aérien qui
était quand commencer et puis certaines
entreprises ont attendu et ont joué un
peu des jeux là dessus donc
effectivement il ya des entreprises
toujours qui ne jouent pas le jeu on
ad'autres bains ont un peu l'impression
que sur alcatel c'était inéluctable
voilà c'est bien triste mais c'était
donc on le découvre aujourd'hui mais moi
c'est pas j'ai à dire cela ça c'est un
peu la vie de l'économie aujourd'hui ils
ont raté des virages bien voilà un
moment la rue on est plein mur c'est les
petites entreprises sur lesquelles je
m'inquiète beaucoup et tous les sous
traitants et cela ça va être plus
difficile
françoise gatel vous partager cette
inquiétude je suis je partage
l'inquiétude de ma collègue parce que
c'est une entreprise qui est installé
dans les côtes d'armor et les côtes
d'armor et notamment lannion ont
longtemps été un phare si je puis dire
en matière de technologie on a vous
recherchez de l'atlantique les choses
alors est ce que l'entreprise
effectivement a su s'inscrire dans des
développements technologiques qui est et
ce qu'il fallait mais je sais qu'ils
souhaitaient et que on va voir pendant
cette crise effectivement des
entreprises qui en quelque sorte dans le
cadre de la crise
je n'ose pas dire elles vont profiter
mais en tout cas on va voir des dégâts
qui de toute façon secrète arrivés et
qu'ils sont accélérées mais qui ne faut
pas que tous les plans dead que l'on
fera pour éviter des licenciements secs
se fasse au détriment de pme qui
courageusement porte l'économie dans les
territoires et porte souvent est ce que
j'appelle la réal économie
qu'on fasse très attention à ça parce
que les entreprises ne comprendre pas et
si au final beaucoup plus d'emplois que
des très grosses et enfin sur
l'aéronautique juste pour dire moi je
comprend ce qui se passait quand même
temps judy sur mer au nautic sur air
france comme sur la sncf je veux bien
qu'on s'inquiète de la santé de ces
entreprises
mais il semble que certaines ont fait
des grèves très coûteuses et qu il
faudrait aussi que les salariés
s'interrogent sur leur part de
responsabilité un milliard le coût de la
grève pour la sncf 4 milliards la
pandémie mien toutefois françoise gatel
mélo milliards avec de trop je suis
désolé on n'était pas obligé de le
dépenser ainsi faire bernard et 5
milliards
mais pour pas faire de réformes est
largement votre réaction à cette à ce
grand moment d'inquiétude tout de même
pour les entreprises et alors que
effectivement le fmi et bien dit que la
france risque d'avoir une contraction de
son pib de 12,5 pour cent la pandémie va
être très grave pour la france au niveau
économique
elle prend des 1000 est très grave pour
les hommes et les femmes qui sont dans
ces entreprises et dans ces secteurs
d'activité et qui perdent leur emploi et
pour autant il faut pas succombé au
syndrome du cheval vapeur
il faut justement maintenant tirer les
leçons de cette pandémie sur tous les
plans et on voit bien qu'ils aient une
volonté de relocalisation l'importance
de recréer des circuits économiques plus
ancré dans les territoires et plus
proche est de favoriser les nouveaux
modes de consommation qu'on a vu émerger
de façon significative notamment les
circuits courts
il faut qu'on accepte d'investir
peut-être un peu plus de notre argent
dans la qualité de notre alimentation et
un peu moins dans des voyages à l'autre
bout du monde veut dire il faut qu'on
investisse un peu plus dans nos
territoires dans cette économie là et
moi je suis convaincu qu'on peut prendre
ce virage et que ce sera profitable pour
l'emploi et pour les hommes et les
femmes de notre pays justement pour
conclure au docteur je me dis qu'est ce
que vous pensez vous et bien du fait que
les entreprises demandent beaucoup la
fin du protocole sanitaire alors que
l'on veut en même temps un certain
nombre de signaux d'inquiétude notamment
avec leur confinement locales en
allemagne il ya une ressort qu'une rue
circulation du virus en fonction
évidemment de l'évolution de nos
comportements donc faut être très
vigilant pour le moment elle est
toutefois totalement encore sous
contrôle et le fait qu'on diagnostique
de nouveaux foyers n'est pas qui est en
soi c'est plutôt le signe que
système de dépistage enfin fonctionne eh
bien merci beaucoup bernard jomier merci
françoise gatel merci jérôme bascher
d'avoir participé à ce débat des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
restez avec nous parce qu'à suivre à 17
heures sur les antennes des chaînes
parlementaires et bien il ya l'audition
du vieux très médiatique docteur raul tu
par la commission denquête de
l'assemblée nationale à 22h ne manquez
pas également allons plus loin avec
rebecca fitoussi très bonne soirée sur
public sénat
[Musique]